what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell so we are going to be
notified of my daily videos couple
announcements before we start the show
um the first is that we have two clips
channels just pearly clips and pearl
daily also guys um make sure you sign up
for our Google form to be notified of
events in London and we are starting a
new podcast where I go over news called
Pearl daily so tune in um we're gonna
post it every day around like I don't
know two three roughly so make sure you
guys tune in um for that but um to start
why don't we do intros everyone say your
name your age relationship status and a
fun fact about yourself starting here
and then go around okay uh I am
Elizabeth Hobson I'm 34. I am single
um yeah I I do have two sons so I
separated from their father a couple of
years ago
um and fun fact
um my favorite comic book hero anti-hero
he's judged red I love Judge Dredd
I don't know who that is oh you've got
so you've got like just the best thing
to discover I'll help okay okay I don't
know what that is good
hello everyone thank you for having us
there's so many fabulous people I'm just
trying to fit in move your mic down a
little bit I am Crystal diver yeah look
I have this thing in front of my face
we're gonna learn to work it I'm 44
years old and um I'm in a long-term
relationship
um fun fact is that I design fragrances
so I work with fragrances and I speak
five languages and I love my book no
what languages uh I speak Lithuanian
Russian polish English and Arabic where
are you originally from I was born in
vellinos Lithuania yo people okay okay I
figured it had to be somewhere in Europe
because everyone there like knows a
million languages like Easter when I was
in Germany I was so shocked everyone
knew three languages at least yeah it's
not because I'm smart it's just life
through me places and I learned along
the way which is blessing really
go ahead hi everybody I only know one
language English
[Music]
yeah that's expected we never know
maybe you don't need to yeah
that's true yeah
you gotta say an age but yeah but Google
translate you know that's what I use now
uh but I'm peachy sues
um I'm 37 I identify as 28. I stick by
that I don't care what people say about
it and this is delusion you know you
can't identify us you can't identify as
10 years younger I cannot listen if we
can change genders we can change age
I don't think I'm wrong I identify I
identify as Jeff Bezos
you know what Anna Delphi did it why not
who and adelva you don't know Anna
Delphi no she's one of the greatest
criminals oh my the you
she she lied and said she was like a
French heiress and she lived off of
other people's wealth for years staying
at like the Ritz and all that in New
York and I tell me there's a whole
Netflix special about her German Russian
oh oh I think I know who that is the
girl that made that face she made the
fake company yes yes yes yes yes okay
yeah fake billions you can identify a
chef Basil hey Jeff
God God all right I'm Johnny Cassell I'm
34. I'm occupation is I'm a dating and
men's lifestyle strategist predominantly
help men but I do help a lot of women
also the Smart Ones help me please
so today's topic are women needed in
society yes yes so so I had a tweet on
Twitter now I've been tweeting a lot
lately guys follow my Twitter
pearlythings with a z at the end uh can
you put it up on the screen so I said
outside of reproduction
um Society I I can't read it I need you
to put it up if you don't mind
um
oh I gotta remember oh outside of
reproduction society would function fine
without women yeah and I had a video now
I know this sounds crazy you're like
what how could you think that but I I
put a very nice video to explain My
Views so
you know pull pull the clip King
Enlighten us yes
we got this couple man woman right what
does society like what do we need for
society to work we need a house
um we might need the internet right I
mean we don't we don't need it but we we
all you know we need a car
hypothetically we live in like I know I
can't draw I can't draw so just you know
bear with me
um we need electricity we need plumbing
and what percent of women do these jobs
I can't really think of one job where
women Dominate and that we need what up
guys welcome to the dust pearly things
YouTube channel today I am going to be
giving a special whiteboard presentation
called ladies you are not as special as
you think well actually a better a
better name for this would be ladies
you're not as important as you think yes
now I get a lot of hate for for I got a
lot of hate this week for a tweet that I
said that said men make Society run and
women don't our jobs we get all the
women women could stop working tomorrow
so what do I mean by that what if we
have a society right so we got a guy
here what what do we you know maybe I'll
make it orange so it's a little darker
another guy here all right we got this
couple man woman right what does society
like what do we need for society to work
we need a house
um we might need the internet right I
mean we don't we don't need it but we we
all you know we need a car
hypothetically if you live in like I
know I can't draw I can't draw so just
you know bear with me
um we need electricity we need plumbing
and what percent of women do these jobs
so it's roughly 90 plus percent of men
are building the houses they're building
the cars they're doing the electricity
they're doing the plumbing
um I can't really think of one job where
women Dominate and that we need now this
is what they'll tell me right because I
got some I got some haters shock they'll
say well women work at the MV women are
teachers and health care now here's
here's the problem all of these jobs men
could easily learn on top of that
Healthcare is still roughly 50 50 and
men still lead the way in healthcare
when it comes to the most competitive
and hardest jobs like brain surgery you
know research development even
inventions 80 men so my question is if
let's just say the green guy is the guy
if the men are making the society run
why are women starting to out earn men
because that's a new feminist talking
point that I hear oh well the women are
coming up now you know we're starting to
out earn men now I'm going to give you
two reasons that women are out earning
men we can monetize and I'm going to
give you an example of this at the
highest levels who offers more value to
society Kim Kardashian or Elon Musk
Kylie Jenner Elon Musk or Kylie Jenner
Bill Gates these are two female
billionaires and two male billionaires
the male billionaire is trying to put
Life on Mars electric cars
um you know software companies where the
female billionaires are monetizing
Beauty
um so that's one way that women out earn
men and we can even see this in
Corporate America like women I worked in
sales as a woman you have as have an
inherent advantage in sales because
you're a woman you're pretty to look at
they're going to talk to you easier than
a man and the men know this so you know
typically when women do get ahead it's
in places where you can monetize your
beauty now the second place reason
subsidizing there are a bunch of
government jobs and grants that reward
Corporate America for hiring women so we
take tax paying the man friends and we
give it to the women because you know
they tax the men take the money from the
men and create Grant and programs to
reward Corporate America for hiring
women but does that mean the women are
offering equally as much value no so the
crazy thing is is that women are getting
these high paying jobs that men are
really paying for and guys you're going
to ask me the data numbers but let's
just look in real life what happened at
Twitter Elon Musk said okay we got to
make money we're losing money look at
the before and after picture they got
rid of all the women all the women were
gone there was just a couple left now
this is not to say that women have no
place in society but as a whole we all
think we're more important than we are
you know there's always been exceptions
in history for you know high IQ women
making advancements in society but it's
the exception it's not the rule and
unfortunately I'm also really tired
tired of us acting like teachers are
like a godsend one all of these you know
the crazy thing is the industries that
women run are the industries We complain
about so Healthcare is mostly women
we're always complaining about how
health care is not there to help you
same with teachers okay colleges the
institutions run by women we all
complain about so one the teachers are
these single feminist women that don't
have kids of their own so they just try
to indoctrinate yours um Healthcare
everybody complains about how health
care gives you drugs and it doesn't fix
the problem so let's be honest if women
left left work and went back into the
home you would need less health care
because you'd actually have the mother
caring about what the kids eat we have a
whole generation of people that don't
know how to cook that don't know proper
nutrition because the mom instead of
being at home was busy teaching other
kids working in healthcare working at
the DMV all right then teaching now you
have the state teaching your kids where
again if the mom was home
she could homeschool the kids and you
wouldn't need any of these industries so
my point is if women stopped working
tomorrow I actually I think we would
have an increase in efficiency not a
decrease not a decrease and the problem
is we have all these women that think
they're doing more than they are because
they're hot and they make money off of
being hot and they're subsidized by the
government so yeah ladies we are not as
special as we think we are but you know
could be wrong let me know what you guys
think of the cop so so let me let me
know what you guys you went in am I off
base am I Maybe I'm Wrong tell me
I'm gonna say this right first of all
I'd love the breakdown I love how you
really thought about it right but all I
could think is why do you need women in
society because women again do make the
world go wrong but do you think a man
would get out of bed and work and
actually try to achieve good things if
it weren't for trying to gain a woman's
attention a man could sleep on a bench
and be happy and sleep outside they earn
money do everything they do to impress
me so so I was thinking about this too
okay I was like let me think what would
Society look like if women disappeared
outside of I know we give them the kids
but let's take the kids out of this the
family okay and I was thinking I'm like
would men still explore I think yes
would men still build things I think yes
I think there's an innate nature of men
that want to build things explore the
world and they did do this on a TV show
they took the men on one Island and they
put with women on the one Island and
they said survive and the women had to
be saved within a day the men had like
water going they had houses they all had
their assigned roles where the women
were just like arguing about who could
do what and so I do think we wouldn't
have roombas because I think they built
those for women I think we wouldn't have
a dishwasher but I think and everything
would probably be plainer like we
wouldn't have like like guys don't see
the point of these pillows stuff like
that but I think we would still have a
society no definitely not like there's
something about a woman right men they
have egos so when you get in these rooms
with men and let's say they're trying to
even make simple decisions what are they
going to do sit there and argue with
each other because they're going to want
to be right this is when you need that
woman in society who is the level head
to be like hey here goes oh this is okay
let's let's no no let's take this okay
who argues more men or women let's let's
think of well if it really depends on
the character of the person isn't it
where are you from in your background I
think women love to argue more than men
every war has been started by a man
though not true actually that's what
they tell you last five let no no no see
I looked into this stuff
back to you to know this you're just you
know off the streets
email rulers in the male rulers and you
know who is more likely to wage war the
women so this idea that like men and I
and I tell you why I think that is women
of no consequence for anything when it
comes to violence because the men will
fight for them that's why you see the
women like talking at the bar the
men don't do that like the men will
fight for the women yes and in the UK
Parliament as well though when we've
gone in into Iraq and Syria the female
MPS were significantly more likely to
vote for the intervention and I think
actually perhaps with them there was an
element of social acceptability you know
they were whipped to do it by the party
whips and it was you know when we went
into Iraq we had this fake story about
weapons of mass destruction and it was
like you know
they correct response at the time based
on the blatantly fake evidence that
someone with a more logical rational
perspective who maybe has
spent time engaging with more historical
literature which you know these kind of
special interests are more likely to be
held by men especially in the House of
Commons whereas women go in there
wanting to represent women and
you know Trump all these feminist causes
it's interesting how you separate like
okay women with this men are good at
this is actually how the life treat us
and probably I believe that a lot of
things we take from and how we grow is
from our childhood and our experiences
in childhood so it's absolutely not
necessary that the man is good at
something and the woman is good at
cooking it can be the other way around I
am crap at physics and my son is like
super mega wizard at physics I would
never be able to homeschool him to the
level of physics that he's actually
deserves so this is there are
Specialists I looked I actually I
learned something today so apparently
the education system has been falling
since the 80s it's been getting worse
but it's not women it's politics I'll
tell you why I'll tell you why actually
we have we have a teacher and a
teacher's aide so it used to be male
dominated before the 80s and after the
80s it was female dominant you have to
know this stuff right yeah and so now
I'm like wait when the women came in we
taught worse than the guys
and we had two women
no I don't know so our schools where I
am from which is no it's true we're from
West London yeah a lot of our schools
are outstanding and the children come
out and they go into universities and
they go into Mensa society and I have to
disagree with you what the task scores
don't it's in the U.S too their test
scores have been falling since like the
70s like we can't even pass um 11th
grade tests from back then wow maybe I'm
just blessed to live around smart people
yeah so my premise is I really think if
women all went home tomorrow I think
society would function fine I'm not
saying some Industries wouldn't take a
hit I think some would
but but I think HR departments would
disappear tomorrow yeah yeah who's who's
filing the HR claim that's not the men
it's the women come on everybody HR
would disappear tomorrow I think
um yeah and I and I think society would
still run but if the men stopped working
I think that society would Crash and
Burn we'd maybe survive 30 days who
leads in the Ponzi scheme game men so do
you really trust a lot of men with money
not me I trust him more than women we
have 80 of the debt women yeah yeah
women of 80 of the debt even though we
make less money
that's because I'm not talking about you
not talking about you talking about I'm
good with money yes
brilliant I'm looking about us as a
whole as a group but if you look at
women out of whole 80 of us are in debt
probably because they have a household
to take care of because the men got up
and left not true if they have a
household if they have children and they
have to take on the leadership role
especially if they have to be in society
working well of course well the men
didn't leave the women leave and that's
really clear 70 to 80 percent of the
time women file for divorce and a lot of
times we make children with men that are
not husbands
disappear what pregnancy what about that
this would disappear as soon as they
find out that the department is pregnant
well I've found that the majority of the
time when that happens it's because a
woman's in some sort of situationship
she's trying to trap a man and then and
then now she's like maybe he'll commit
and he's like no I will not lady now for
now but but but number two and that's
that song that's not common though
because the majority of the time men do
stay so with four different difference
this is just one kids with four
different women he's not Daddy to any of
them
that's four stupid women and one stupid
man
is so smart I do I do think it's whoever
I do think it women you are in charge of
who your baby father is I think that is
your fault don't hate the play I hate
the game right and at the end of the day
you at least I always say it that these
men always come as everybody comes into
a relationship with their representative
hey I'm gonna show you my good side but
it is facts facts facts facts that once
a woman gets pregnant that's it the
relationship literally goes into the
toilet after that after the woman like
the woman switches up no after after a
child anytime you bring a child into a
situation that's it like bring a baby in
everybody's stress bills go up lack of
intimacy is so many things that lead to
that so men are not if women are leaving
it's only because men have checked out
of the situation and checked out of
their duties a long time before no no
they list the reasons they leave and
it's it's like irreconcilable
differences it's money sometimes it's
infidelity they don't even say on which
side but it's pretty split on Fidelity
it's roughly 50. women actually are out
cheating men under 30. yeah women are
out there yeah yeah yeah
but I'm saying like what you're saying
isn't true that the men are leaving it's
the women leaving yeah but and like
every data they're filing for the
divorce but what's leading to the
divorce if I'm a woman at home with your
your kids and I'm taking care of the
householder I'm I'm being faithful to
you and just because you're paying the
bills you're out you know sleeping with
every Sarah and Jessica that walks so
I'll give you a couple numbers that's
only a small percentage of men that can
sleep with multiple women so it's only
like 15 to 20 percent of men maybe 30
tops I mean it's so the majority of men
cannot sleep with multiple women so it's
not them cheating well even if they
sleep with one woman it's still cheap
like women no no
like women find 80 of men is
unattractive ugly not not just okay not
decent we find 80 percent of men is ugly
I love ugly men I sleep with ugly men
all the time
that we're not cheating with them well I
mean I'm not a cheater but I'm saying
like as women in whole like a lot of
times women wear emotional cheaters we
don't necessarily cheat there's you know
some women might cheat off of looks but
when we decide to step out of
relationship it is always because
emotionally at home something is being
neglected and we found that in somebody
else yes fingers both ways men and women
when you lack something in the
relationship you look for it elsewhere
if you try to deal with it first and you
ask and you address the issue and you
try to resolve it within and then
another you know I don't know 10 eight
years later and nothing has happened to
be resolved just promises promises
promises then this is where infidelity
comes in and I mean it's sad but but
it's interesting because it's like you
guys whenever the woman does something
wrong like she leaves or she cheats it's
always like well why
no no you guys didn't give that benefit
of the doubt to the dad who left that
there wasn't no why did he leave what
four times
you know what it is because it's
expected of a man like you expect it's
very hard like you've got to think about
when the Earth was made men back then
were having multiple wives so now we
have this thing where okay you know
they're bringing polygamy back but
before they really brought polygamy back
now we have this thing where you know
it's one in one well that's not in a
man's nature well it's actually women
are picking polygamy I actually think
that monogamy benefits more men than
benefits women
because when we're in monogamy that
means like more men are getting laid
that means like 60 70. but it's funny no
I'm serious when it's funny one out of
three men are virgins or haven't had sex
in the past year and that's that's
primarily the switches when women have
more mate selection so 100 years ago
that was when women started to move into
apartments and be able to basically like
be on their own that makes sense before
it was like yeah before it was like
dad's house husband's house there was no
in between and it's funny because the
more mate selection we have the stupider
we are yeah we'll go for it yes yes but
the soul is the bigger the menu you
don't know what to eat but we'll go for
a smaller and smaller percentage of men
so it's like we'll go for 10 20 30 of
men I've had so many girls come on the
show and say they've dated a celebrity
their average chicks do you think she
was the only one how many girlfriends is
Chris Brown how many girlfriends did a
great how many girlfriends Stills like
all of these high value you know guys
have but did he know he's dating her too
that part
I know it's dated like they say but but
the fact that the fact that you know
this shows it's coming back right where
the girls like we're dating and it's but
we outnumber men so really it's the men
that have more choices like dating is
like one to eight it's like one man from
every eight women no it's not it's 50.
it's 55 man it's 45 women it's not it's
our other way around 55 women 45 men but
if you actually look like eligible men
when it comes to dating if you look like
eligible men men
not even just age the ones that are not
in jail that are not dead what percent
of the population
I've dated men in jail before I live in
New York you have to date a man
you know you might talk to a guy you
literally can go to the corner store in
New York and get locked up like there is
no you know so you can be dating a guy
and he gets locked up that's happened to
me a couple of times it's one percent of
the population for what that's in jail
yeah but if you actually think of like
eligible single Bachelors right who's
not married who's not dead that's one
out of every 20 for a lifetime so five
percent
it's like taking starter of the menu all
the men now and I don't want to bring it
I don't want to offend anybody but
there's a lot of gay men in the world
now so if you add that into it who's
really left for women single men that
are actually left four women I mean I
would argue what women are left for men
a lot no no if you look okay if you look
by and a lot of people think I hate on
women but it's just if you look at an
evolutionary point of view most women
today would be cast out
yeah like based on what age for one like
over 30 you were kind of done
um kids from other marriages or hot guys
done
um not being a virgin on your wedding
night your chance of being married was
like no you're a concubine at that point
but 95 of women are not virgins on their
wedding I'm not I'm not saying we have
to but if we're going for historical
from a historical point of view most
women today would have been thrown out
what percentage of male are Virgin Under
a wedding well but women but women don't
but women don't select for that like
women don't give a about a man's
virginity true women don't care about
purity so it's not the same stability is
what we're like dirty most women after a
certain age go for it yeah but women
still out earn men you know it's funny
because women like if we're gonna go for
Traditional Values like maybe men don't
make like enough for one income but they
still make more money
um than women but I would say most women
are more sexually experienced than most
men
I doubt that this doesn't sound right
because yeah because I just one out of
three men are either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past year I don't want to
see that same Trend but I don't see that
same Trend in women when you when you
look at those statistics you gotta
remember that's just a a like a small
population that they sit there and and
you know study and ask these questions
so this is not in no no they got no they
got it from
um doctors I think that's how they
gathered that data it was from everybody
are you kidding me I bet we could argue
they're lying by 10 but if they do it in
multiple cities and they're coming up
with the same conclusion in the west you
start to see a trend but this is what
you know what I'm saying because like
like I mean if you want to take like
body count statistics for women tend to
be way more variable than like men
because again they'll do it in different
cities to see
but which is but it's still a targeted
populated audience it's not like in
whole because if you actually look at it
in whole and you like fairly went to
every single different group every
cultural race wise all of that those
statistics would be so much different
but they sit there and it's a certain
audience they target so they can get the
results that they want to get in
multiples it's like so in multiple
cities they're all talking to each other
and saying try to get these results when
we're talking about worldwide so when
you're in the west it's like they've
done it in different cities and it's
roughly the same Europe
UK and U.S okay so if you look in the UK
and U.S right did they sit there and go
to the same demographic as far as like
hospitals or whatever like did they sit
there and go to maybe all of the
well-to-do hospitals or were they going
to the hood as well accidents like were
they going into every single region cult
like different cultural regions to get
these statistics probably not it was
probably one set group that they wanted
what numbers would you like to go off of
that I mean like I said it's different
I'm a black woman so the statistics that
are given to us is actually one in 23.
black women dating a single black man so
it's it it that's why we're 123 what
like as far as like to get a single man
one in 23 for black women to get a
single black man like that's that's what
we're looking at three women at one
month 23 women to one man wow
I thought there it was like 45 were
single child listen in the middle class
of black men I I could be wrong but I
thought it was like 35 to 45 but a
single straight
black man single straight black man this
is why it's so hard this is why so many
black women are unmarried and it is hard
for us to get married because we are
fighting with
thousands of other women just to get one
man well but but this is the problem as
women it's like we'll kind of blame the
men instead of looking at the quality of
women and because the trend of women not
getting married is across the board like
like I think white women it's 50 like
and and every generation it's coming
less and less and less so a lot of times
it's like we'll blame the men when it's
like we don't look at the quality of the
women but these are good these are good
quality women these are doctors these
are lawyers these are great
but you're looking at the things that
like men want in like that women want in
men like men don't care about your
career they don't care if you're a
doctor they don't care if you're a
lawyer they don't care if you make money
they just want you to be hot but which
is true but think about it if you're a
man and you have 20 different hot women
in front of you it's like the Hunger
Games you're literally playing The
Hunger Games to get a man these days
just I think that you're kind of removed
from the average males experience dating
because I I don't think that's the
average guy's experience dating at all
that what there's many women to choose
from no the app the average oh
raffle there's definitely
if you look at each man right the
average man he's at least probably
talking to Six Women no no he doesn't
get no because the data shows up the
number one way people under 30 are
meeting is dating apps yes so so a lot
of people say dating apps isn't real
life but it is now that's the number one
way that people are meeting under 30. so
what percent of the time do you think
women swipe right and say yes I'd like
to go on a date with this man
just swipe just a swipe not even what
percent yeah it's vanishingly small
isn't it like what one in 20 pictures or
something like that 120 okay what do you
think no idea I've never been another
one but I have actually friends who met
on Tinder and got married okay but what
percent what percent what the percent of
of men do you think uh oh how many picks
she swipes until she says yeah what
percent
um
um let's say 35 okay 35 what do you
think as an avid dating app user I would
probably say less than 10 is less than
10 what do you think yeah I'd say one in
fifty it's five percent
so if women the number one way people
are meeting is dating apps and we're
only swiping right five percent of the
time how is it how is a guy going to
talk to six chicks at a time
abilities
we try to date smarter as women we go on
these dating apps a lot of time because
it's easier for us to you know not waste
our time in public like
some men may have been intimidated to
come up and walk to a woman and be like
hey let me come hit on you or whatever
like that okay so how how many girls how
many girls does a guy typically have to
approach to get a number
I would say probably like every 15 to 20
girls maybe 18 to 20 years are you yeah
I mean it depends on someone's ability
and you know how much reference they
have but I mean if I was out of a guy
and seeing him throw it down he's
probably gonna do 10 interactions until
he finds one what what kind of average
are we talking about though are we
talking about
you know the average for Johnny or are
we talking about the average woman
average girl okay all men how many
earners like how many how many women are
they gonna have to approach to get a
number and like they're not gonna you
know like there's no there's no trickery
like yeah oh I've got a well I was gonna
parcel it's yours can I borrow your
number like this is legitimate yeah we
know what it's about yeah
um I'm working with these guys I mean I
think that this
well yeah but I I don't think they're
average men Johnny you've been taking
them to India to meet the Dalai Lama
that's a certain sect but that's not
yeah not all the guys to be quite honest
um I think that there are
a huge number of men who could walk
around asking women for their number for
the rest of their lives and they
wouldn't get one
so you said you do this all the time
yeah I've had 15 years of experience
doing it okay tell me tell me your
experience what I mean you know you've
got the opportunity to meet someone for
the first time as soon as you leave your
house and that's we like to encourage
people to do men or women
um when it comes to strategy you've got
to have a bit of an audit on how you
live in your life
where you're spending it who you
spending it with
and be honest is it giving you a good
return on your time if not let's move
some parts around to get that better
return on your time who's giving you the
access to the demographic that you want
and also you need to improve your
confidence you need to do it you need to
start talking to people you're going to
get shot down it's going to hurt but
you're going to get better and then
eventually you're going to show up as
the version that they want to experience
of you and that's when you start getting
a higher percentage of of their contact
details and then I think though there is
a real difficulty for young men in
particular they've been fed these
messages that women are all terrified of
them and a lot of women are at actually
terrified of them feminism is teaching
women that actually in any you know if
if a man gets a chance he will want to
SAU or whatever yeah um and so yeah boys
or young men are scared to try
because they don't want to scare a woman
um and you know if they don't try then
they're not going to build the
confidence they're not going to build
the resilience they're never going to
learn how to do it and it's not only the
societal messages we've got you know the
force of the law behind
um you know it's kind of misogyny as I
hate crime laws and all of this kind of
stuff that is threatening and certainly
HR departments you know you go and ask
one of your colleagues who if you're say
a man who's not overly confident but he
knows this woman because he works with
her all the time so maybe he could ask
her for a coffee
if she responds badly and goes to HR
he's lost his job it's
I'm sorry I know someone that got kicked
out of a gym for looking at a girl the
wrong way
um he got kicked out I bet I bet that
the evidence was on her phone as she
filmed herself for tick tock now he was
crazy she was wearing the
outfit and so women will wear these
trashy outfits that clearly men are
going to want to lose the office and
then they get mad that when they look
it's like what did you think was gonna
happen it's like at the gym yeah they do
stretches overly they're like they're
like in your face like me as a girl I
could I'm like oh my god let's just me
go but you have so what to do with the
man we as women are fighting for
equality I know people hate that right
I'm not a feminist that sometimes I do
have feminist ways I'm not a feminist
but I do believe that you should have
the right to wear what you want if I
want to go I'm going to be hot in the
gym right so why can't I work out in
something that small what am I supposed
to wear sweatpants and a nightgown what
do you need yeah so men can control them
because I respect people you can you can
wear what you want but don't whine about
the consequences yeah don't tell them oh
my God I hate whiners
it's like okay that's fine go go go
dress like a hooker I don't whine when
men look I I agree with you to an extent
but two I don't think women can ever be
equal to men never but do they need to
be we can be equal as an understanding
we are not the same we should celebrate
our differences and our similarities and
work together as a team and not say oh
my God I want to be I don't want to be
same like dude I want to be me and that
is okay it's just you find your own ways
to work as a team and this separation of
like oh my God let me be like a man but
then if he doesn't pay the full bill
right when he invites me for the dinner
I get offended because he asked me to
split 50 50. but it's not about that I
can pay for a whole dinner today and he
can pay for it tomorrow and it's not
about offenses about communication but
when you were saying like you're
fighting for equality I don't think
women can ever be equal to men because
men will always have to enforce like
women will always have to ask men to
enforce our rights I don't the thing is
I don't think women how how would you
enforce it so if I said Okay I want men
to stop
um looking at me in the gym how would we
enforce that I'd have to go to the men
and say enforce them you go to women's
gym only no but but I'm saying in a
society how do you how do you get the
gym yeah how do you how do if I wanted
to start a woman's gym then how do I how
do I start it easy I have to go to come
to me I'll help him no no no I'm saying
like I have to go I have to get a
building right how do you get a building
the men have to build it so everything
we do in society relies on men I
couldn't I couldn't I couldn't do this
without the microphone that men invented
the building that men built the plumbing
that men installed the elections
those Industries are like 95 plus
percent I understand like a manual
workers are mostly men yes you are
correct inventions because they are
stronger and let's be honest physically
built men are they they are built
stronger than women are and that's okay
however we do other jobs that involve
the building as uh Administration and
all accounting and I don't know all the
different kind of jobs when women do we
think the paperwork is equally as needed
as the building the building no idea yes
because yes think about it if you're
building I need you to just like think
okay wait wait I just want to repeat it
so the girl doing the paperwork is
equally as important we could we need
her just as much as the man laying down
the bricks for the building and the
concrete the contracts the the the the
paperwork of how is it going to be how
is it going to be built all the things
you seriously believe now listen you can
sit there and you could build this
building right but if you don't have the
right if you have no money nothing
behind it her to do it's gonna be a show
okay okay so where would they get the
financing from
it's a lot of women bankers and a lot of
women actually work with like mortgages
and sorry you realize we can literally
walk out into the jungle and build a
house without financing and people yes
of course but it's not the gym is it no
that's not the point is
building a house doesn't require
paperwork yes we just were discussing
about women building gyms
importance importance so what we say
importance right if we're talking about
society different things we're talking
about in society right if you want to
have a functioning business yes that man
might build that business but what is
going to keep it running you could build
the business all you want how is it
going to run man you have to have that
paper trail you have to have who owes me
money you need you need that
organization should men not do that of
course organized cannot women do that
build and organize it we're not strong
enough they could barely build an
organizer family I don't I don't I don't
see why like men ran Society for all of
history I don't see why this time is
with the women or their backbone that's
that's like this delusion that women
think that everything men do is because
of them
I
it is I didn't see the problem with the
running Society or having higher paid
jobs than women we're all different we
should be doing things we are good at
not because someone said so it's a girly
things or manly things we should do
things we're good at and that would be
beautiful and I agree with you but my
point is one the jobs that men do are
necessary for the backbone of society we
could not survive without them but we
cannot do that women do okay so I'm
gonna read you some numbers okay of the
top professions
that men and women do and we'll just as
a group decide which ones are more
important maybe I'm crazy I don't know
maybe they'll let them go okay okay no
no no we gotta pick one not equal we
gotta you gotta pick one one's more
important
all right in the US
93.8 of construction workers are men in
the UK 99 of construction workers are
men 99 of plumbers and pipefitters in
the U.S are men
98.5 percent of plumbers are men in the
UK 95.5 of sewage disposal workers are
men in the U.S 99 of sewage disposal
workers in the UK are men vehicle
technicians 99 meant Carpenters 98 men's
electricians and electrical Fitters 98
men metal workers 98 men plumbers and
heaters 98 men machine drivers and
operators 97 men forklift drivers 97 men
large vehicle delivery drivers now 97
men on-site construction workers 95 men
window Fabricators 96 men so now let's
talk about the women nurses and nurses
assistants 97 women legal secretaries 96
Women Medical secretaries 94 women day
care workers 94 women personal
assistance 94 women teaching assistants
90 women school secretaries 90 women
therapists 89 women housekeepers 89
women dancers 89 percent women so so
what which would you guys if you had to
guess is more needed if you had to pick
one you have to pick okay no equal uh
yeah nurses can't help you if there's
not sanitation we need the men for the
Practical running of society
what about you I I cannot pick I know
you are amazing no you have to pick it
yeah you got it you gotta answer the
question can I just uh just no no drop a
little message
I need I need one pick one
really strong women and we were doing
all these jobs we were doing building
painting driving uh everything literally
we're doing everything from gardening to
building to carrying things so for me
it's like really weird that these things
are separate into two male and women and
female jobs just things you're good at
are you are crap at as simple as that
okay go ahead so I'm gonna go with women
because for
life right you can have all of this
stuff but for life to keep on Surviving
and keep on going on and thriving you
need the women you know what did I start
with listen what did I start with I said
no reproduction we're taking that out of
this no no when I say life I don't mean
reproduction reproduction I mean just in
general if you get sick okay where do
you have to go right okay
you just died okay
so what's what's more needed a doctor or
a nurse
nurse practitioners do the same thing as
a doctor so okay okay and where where do
they do their job at a hospital which is
built by
maybe built by men but everything
let me say one thing all of the jobs you
described were if you live in a thriving
city right go to another place in the
world where they don't have buildings
and all of that you don't need the men
because the women can sit there and and
build as well with sticks and stuff so
okay
again they tried this they really tried
this they went out into the Wilderness
they put men on an island did they put
women on an island and they said survive
the men because men naturally
order themself with hierarchy so the men
will say you do this you do this they'll
naturally listen to the most competent
men men like size each other up in a
room I don't get it I'm a woman but
that's just what they do women would
just bicker
and they they Trend more towards
egalitarianism we're all equal
so they they literally had to be rescued
within like two days but what the men
then we go next time too but what but
again what type of woman is that of you
if you're gonna pick 10 women who you
know have you know jobs where they're
not getting their hands wet and they've
never really been out and doing this
dude all of the women are not picking
these jobs
so I just listed to you all the women
there's no barriers we can work whatever
we want it's not strong we're not our
event is different we are built
differently it's not even that you know
what a big initiative that they're doing
in America right now a big initiative is
that they're trying to get more women
into these spaces physics and Pilots all
different types of stuff like that
because if you think about it convince
us to do the hard job they're doing it
women women are doing it no no no men
still out one one way is engineering and
the men are still there's all these
programs to get women in engineering I
might
um roommate my freshman year was an
engineer all these programs all these
grants basically had free school for her
they can't convince women to do these
jobs but it has to start so if I'm
growing up and I'm taught that do this
do this do that that's what I'm going to
go at the more and more that we show
women you can work in this field the
more and more and we're just now we're
coming out for over 50 years that's all
we heard growing up you can do anything
but yeah
but once you actually start seeing women
that are top Engineers top there's now
more women are going to be like oh okay
A woman has done and then you also got
to think the competition in the world I
disagree that if I'm a construction
workers I don't need to I don't think
that would you like to work in
construction
I think it's attractive no but this is
what I'm saying if me and you both show
up to a construction site who do you
think they're going to hire first
they're going to hire you I would guess
you because there's all these government
grants especially in those Industries
yeah
about this topic I know a lot about it
let's get helmets and boots and get it
on but I like it if you took that out of
it if you really took that out of it we
were like like seriously if we both show
up they're gonna go for the mail so a
lot of times these women try to get jobs
in these these these you know uh job
these all right I'll tell you something
I went I went to college and I studied
engineering I was actually going to go
into Motorsport engineer and that was my
passion that's what I wanted to do and
as I was studying it you know as you
could imagine it's predominantly all men
boys should we say
um but there's one girl
and you could see it was something in
there that she she wanted to go that
direction she wanted to go against the
grain she wanted to get her hands dirty
and um
you know and then I went to see her in a
work placement and then after a year or
two she just dropped out she wanted she
she didn't want to be in a masculine she
wanted to be in touch with a feminine so
she found something that was more Suited
towards that and um
you know that's my reference point I I
think it may sound attractive to go in
that direction but I don't think that
you would be selected as a mate
because it's it's not feminine what
decided you enjoy your job or not or you
do it but it's not about well it's not
about that it gets to a point where it's
just like men aren't finding me
attractive
oh men are not finding her attractive
because she's doing a manly job yeah and
I'm I'm seeing this is a big big thing
in society at the moment where
we're experiencing a lot more women that
are stepping into the masculine
and
they're not being selected they end up
single because they're they are seen as
a threat
not too much I think their scene is not
the materials right I think men want
yeah pretty and agreeable and pleasant
and interesting but also they want a
woman who will look after their children
well and if you've got a woman who has
been so focused on her career you know
it's like is the kid even going to be
breastfed or is she going to be like
I've done the six weeks maternity leave
I'm back to the office like give the kid
to anyone but but it's also as well like
if you are in a relationship and your
job wants you to have these masculine
traits then you're going to take their
energy back into the home and then what
happens is the man then feels like he
hasn't got a place
so the polarity is off
and that's when he starts to lose
interest and find someone that does lamb
to
Men start earning more money so they can
fully take care of women so women don't
have to go out it's not necessarily that
it's just it's just always it's
we're seeing a rise in femininity
coaches right now it's prevalent there
is more need than ever for for these
people these modalities and they're just
helping women get back in touch with
their feminine side and if you can have
these jobs but make sure that you've
you're not losing that side yourself
don't bring it in my question for you is
why do you always put it on the men like
the men need to earn more why don't the
women be more of wife material because
because most women even if they met a
guy that could provide all of the bills
and like I meet guys that want to take
care of the their women all the time but
there's not a lot of wives on the market
right now like women that actually know
how to be a wife which is well which is
true because again the way you are
raised the way you're brought up
definitely affects how you're going to
be as an adult so if you come where
you're used to working and all that yes
there are women that do need to learn
how to be wives yes I agree with that
but why I say it comes down to the men
men stop taking care of women in the
households and women were forced to go
get jobs so once you're out there
getting a job once you're watching
somebody that's not true though they
were not forced
this is what the government no the
government the government said hey we'll
pay you guys to leave here is money for
being a single mother the women did not
have to take it so how are they going to
provide for their kids so no before the
fathers were in the home a hundred years
ago 85 percent of people were married
and they stayed married I don't know
exactly what the divorce rate was but I
know it was significantly lower now
people don't even want to get married
because the divorce laws are so bad
but but my my whole point is women are
offered incentives to leave so if you
leave you get money from the government
if you leave you can take money from his
pocket and women choose to take that but
at the same time say that they're equal
well if you're equal to a man then be a
man pay your own way but I don't think
that women choose to take that I I
definitely believe that the government
has broken up families that's why like
you said they offer the money and all
that so the government definitely has a
hand in bringing up a lot of families
but how is the woman supposed to survive
if I get pregnant I have to take care of
a child I can't take that child I say I
say give the kid to the person that can
afford it it doesn't make sense for you
to have the kid if you can't afford it
so you leave the family and now he has
to pay for it but how is it and the
majority and the majority of women are
the ones that leave so the idea that men
leave and a lot of people think that
generation of men left but it's actually
the women mostly drove them out of the
house and left if you look at the
numbers it doesn't support the deadbeat
like Dad narrative it's not there but if
you okay so
you can but that's the thing if you're
looking at statistics that's just what
people are reporting if you actually in
real life what is driving so and you
know I've done a lot of these interviews
because I I interview guys that have
like um that are trying to get custody
of their kids women can be very spiteful
and use the kids as a pawn to hurt the
dad but are men only trying to get the
custody so they don't have to pay child
support because a lot of times there's
men who fight to try to get custody
because they don't want to pay
one I don't think men should pay any
child support I I think I think if you
leave that's like that's on you
I I that's my personal opinion I don't
know why we're rewarding bad behaviors
I would say I would say the kids and
that's why dads should be awarded
custody off the bat because every every
data statistic will tell you that single
father homes fare better than single
mother homes well yeah but when
um Parents separate it is the as close
to equal time with both parents that is
the it provides the best outcomes and so
that is what you're aiming for like as
close to 50 50 as is humanly possible
so let me ask you this question you say
that men are needed to build these homes
build everything sewage plummets how are
they going to do that if they have
custody of the kid who's going to watch
the kid well I I think the person that
can afford the kids should have that
choice so he can still like it's not
like I'm saying he should never give the
mother access but I think he should have
the primary decision so what does it
mean I I think I think
what he opportunity well I'd imagine men
aren't as spiteful as women they'd be
much more willing to let the mother like
watch the kids the women are the ones
that use the kids as a tool they
certainly agree with you I agree with
you with that I definitely agree with
you but I will still say if you got if
you think about it men especially alpha
males are not putting in 40 hours a week
they might be putting in 80 hours a week
who is going to if they have custody of
the children who's going to watch the
children so there's a man and a woman
and the woman leaves right right that's
that's the situation we're talking about
that's the situation that I'm talking
about yes and maybe he has to work a lot
okay I think he should get primary
custody and decision making because she
decided to leave and he earns more
meaning he can afford the kids I I'm not
saying that he should not let the mother
see the kids I think when he cannot
watch the kids the mother should if he's
working 80 hours a week she's going to
get plenty of time exactly so if he's
working 80 hours a week he she's going
to have the kids anyway she's the one
who is teaching them their morals their
values they're cooking for them taking
care of them teaching them everything
loving them doing all of that so why
would the man have primary custody why
because he can afford it if he's not
going to be there anyway then like I
mean off the off the bat I think it
should be 50 50 if it's mutual but I'm
saying if the woman chooses to leave I
was saying someone is abused and she
chooses to leave because she's beaten up
or she's just mental abuse various
things various scenarios can be millions
of them what if she chooses to live
because she cannot survive there and she
would be dead if she didn't leave then
what then it's interesting how we always
go to like the worst case scenario it's
realistic yeah they might say it around
those situations do happen and so we
would have to have safeguards so that
women could Escape really unhealthy
relationships
um and so if there was that Safeguard
but if you know unless you proved that
you were abused you knew that the father
was going to get full custody then what
would happen is that false allegations
would Skyrocket I just and you know I
really want to just take the whole uh
child access issue out of the courts you
know you're dealing with families who
are struggling to split up on amicably
and do what's in the best interests of
their children by minimizing conflict
and the way we respond to it is by
throwing it into an adversarial court
system it's insane this is a public
health issue everyone involved needs to
get down to the like psychiatrist's
office and we need to
uh you know
yeah yeah these kids they need both
their parents they need all their
aunties and uncles they need their
grandparents it's so you don't think the
family court system should exist at all
no wow I've never heard that view that's
I agree with you not at all really would
you on the subject that women play up
too much on all these fake allegations
of XYZ and I'm not gonna mention because
it did happen actually I hate it so much
I think that people who falsely allege
someone of a crime that they have not
committed they should be punished of
unequal punishment that would have been
in the court
the family court system is definitely
needed because let's say you're you're
involved with a man right and you think
he put a condom on and he didn't now you
end up pregnant now what all he has to
do is just pick up and leave when you
have a family court system to enforce
that he at least pays for helps pays for
the child like women we already have to
take care of okay I gotta stop you there
you're telling me you didn't notice he
didn't have a condom on there are times
when you don't
what's more common a man pulling off the
condom or a woman lying about being on
birth control
a man even putting on a condom does he
even put it on to begin with where is
your sample size is this just in your
bed
you said where's your sample size yeah
you keep talking about like where's the
demographic we're talking about here is
it like specifically in your bed you're
on birth control
I'm talking about in general about
somebody who you know I traveled where I
talked to different people I you know do
this I used to have a radio show like so
I've talked to millions of people before
and when you're at research and when you
actually sit and talk to people and you
find out their stories and stuff you
you're Gathering up well my question is
why doesn't she require the men she
sleeps with wears condoms you could see
if they put it like this is so no you
could you could you can see if a guy
puts a condom on but how many times do
you turn on Murray and he's taking the
condom off and now she's pregnant who's
the daddy or trying to prove that he is
the daddy all right like it's more
common it that happens more than we
thought you know what that is
interesting though because what is the
response from the public in the audience
in situations where you get into these
kind of real life stories about a man
who slipped the condom off like people
that is not socially acceptable and
people think that he is awful whereas
there was
um a clip that went quite viral I think
it was on Oprah or something like that
and it was you know an audience full of
women and they're having like they're
asking questions and getting responses
from different people and a woman stands
up and she says look
we have
some number of kids two or three kids I
want another but my husband doesn't
should I pretend that I'm taking my
birth control but stop and the entire
audience like all of these women jumped
up hollering saying like do it do it
sister you gotta do it you want that kid
like and that was
I've heard it's stupid I've heard stupid
this feeling stupid I'm just questioning
like there's four guys here do you guys
know any woman that has lied that you
think lied about being on birth control
yeah it happened to me yeah that
happened to you
know anybody do you know anybody wait I
just want raise of hands just there's
four guys in here do you know anybody
I have a woman who's done that I've lied
I'm nothing but okay well I was gonna
ask the women the women have have you
ever been like condom where the guy said
he was wearing a condom and then he took
it off and you didn't know that's never
happened yes yes this happened to me I
choose my partners wisely so no no so
okay so right now we got 25 and 100
this is random people that don't know
each other so it seems like one's more
common than the other they're both a
situations
[Applause]
oh for real
I don't know how you wouldn't notice I
think that women just do that to play
victim I'm gonna be honest I think
that's a lack of like accountability I'm
gonna tell you how you're not gonna
notice right let's say a man is is
hitting it from the front right and he
says flip over let me hit it from the
back and he takes it off because he's
about to climax hello how am I gonna
know all I know is I'm flipping over I'm
not gonna know I'm just gonna know the
film okay he likes this position I'm not
going to be reach down there oh let me
make sure I'm in the moment it happens
that's true it happens what does it put
me if I lied about uh
not taking birth control what I was
taking
oh you lot you lied about it yes I was
taking the birth control and I said I'm
not because oh you were taking that's
really interesting that's a really
interesting question or
ugly
honestly I have
um I have something to say so
responsible
give it to me baby I understand that a
lot of men don't wear condom right yeah
I understand that but I'm kind of
worried if
you're saying that there are men that
would wear the condom and take it off
when they are about to ejaculate that is
wild as hell like that's crazy baby no
no it sounds like a crazy concept but it
is more common than what you think it is
more common you need to think about the
kind of men that would do that that's
the point I'm trying to make those are
not stable individuals I live in New
York everyone's crazy there every single
person is crazy there right so you would
be surprised how many women I have come
across that have said this exact same
thing like men if they're in it and it's
feeling good you know what you know I'll
tell you why they're all sleeping with
the same guys
the only guy in New York but this is
what I mean women select horribly but
that's that's if you're if you're
sleeping with the guy like what does
that say about your decision but you got
to think about it all the good guys are
probably taken so there's only the bozos
like that not only for us to pick from
not true this whole like if you're not
getting good men it's something it says
something about you you are what you
attract these these prison guys
what can I do all the pretty men they
are gay and they don't want me what can
I do
I really think all that does depend on
where you live as well like if you live
in a country somewhere it might be
easier for you to find a good man you
know what I'm saying because it's a
country they preach families marriage
kids all of that if you live in a
thriving overpopulated City
you're worrying about how you're going
to pay bills so everybody's not inclined
to really be on some okay let's get
married let's have children have you
seen all the men in here are not good
men because they live in a populated
city I'm not saying that they're not
they're gorgeous we're gonna go after
party but they're all communities within
our overcrowded cities where most of us
are a complete mess there are
communities who do very well have very
stable families none of our messy issues
yes well what I'm saying is that
depending on where you live will be the
family values and morals that you go for
somebody in South Carolina right out of
high school is more likely to get
married to maybe a high school
sweetheart or something like that
because that is what's preached if you
come to New York that's not priest it's
a whole different it is like listen if
you meet a man he got a good job he
could move on move in with you
know my brother lives in New York he got
married and had a kid like is he still
married yes does he have a phone number
oh no he's still married though but
where where but where are you guys from
where
um I mean I'm from Chicago
which is another people move to New York
so it's like but New York is not a place
known for people to just marry I'm
telling you in New York if you date a
man from New York you are on a 10-year
dating plan you will sit there and date
a man for eight years then he will
finally say let's get married by the
ninth year you're engaged 10th year
you're married well if you get married
everybody up there is more common law
marriages
but I've also heard that the women in
New York aren't marriageable
I've heard they're very career driven
I've heard they're very masculine
they're not very motherly and men will
date a woman for 10 years that they
don't see as wife material break up with
her and then marry the next chick
I wouldn't say we're not motherly I
wouldn't say that I would say are we
career driven yes but think about it
there's so much poverty in New York New
York is an expensive city not everybody
comes from a good background so you're
gonna Thrive to be more career driven
because you have to make it and you hope
along that way you find a man that'll
want to make it with you but I I believe
that women should go back to not working
I wish I could go back so why don't
women in reality but like if we're gonna
go back to traditionalism right so like
again because we have this like
where women want a traditional outcome
but we don't want to be traditional
women I have nothing I have nothing
against wanting to do like do your
career and be modern but where I get
confused is when traditional women ask
for modern for modern women ask for
traditional outcomes
so it's like okay if you want to stay
home and not work why aren't you a
virgin on your wedding day that's
traditional why is he not a virgin no
but that you know that's not you know
that's not the same of course
if your mother teaches you that at a
young age right right if you're good
like when you go to a lot of these
Spanish countries right you see 90 Day
Fiance they always go to a Spanish
country uh you know Asian country and
they get their little nice young wives
because that's what's being taught to
these women how to be a wife how to be
over the age of 18. it's on your it's
your job to learn
so so right now the average age of first
marriage is 30. okay women are getting
married at 30. so now you have 10 years
to figure it out you could surround
yourself by wives right you can learn
how to cook learn how to do the
traditional thing like there's no more
excuses anymore especially with the
internet you can learn what you want to
learn you're in the real world by then
by 18 you're in the real world by then
right so if you really think about it
the average woman might lose her
virginity at 16. right so the average
woman let's say loses her virginity at
16 right and your mother didn't tell you
the values of no sex before marriage or
whatever like that you're already
tempted by okay okay so fine we take the
Purity out of it but there's still other
things you can do to be a traditional
one it's not all about purity I just use
that as an example right that's just one
tenet of it right like you can get a job
working with children
right that would prepare you to be a
mother right you could you could which
is
you could you could but right but but
traditional women it's not about money
it's about family
right you can you could surround
yourself by wives he was talking about
femininity coaches like there's ways
that women can improve we just choose
not to but if we're busy so what you
said earlier yeah let me tell you what
you said earlier you said more women
have their own apartments and these men
are able to come over and this and that
more women no no no no no no no at their
parents home earlier right no well well
then it is then in history yeah yeah so
women move out of their parents home
earlier than a man right man will stay
home longer right we no no I didn't say
that I said before women would go from
the the parents house to the husbands
yeah no but what I'm trying to say is
that in this day and age more women are
getting like their own Apartments
earlier if that's true women can't
afford it so women have way more debt
than men but that's the thing about it
right if women are venturing out early
of course they're going to want to make
more money they're going to want to have
better jobs with them trying to work and
support themselves how are they going to
be able to sit there and be like okay
let me take first of all there's not a
lot of classes that are available to
show show women how to sit there to
femininity classes but having all this
raised and female coaches there's
there's so many classes it's like it's
booming right now like no it's not but
now it is because now women are starting
to be like hey maybe we don't like
there's churches movement but there's
churches you can like find wives like
there's always people you can surround
yourself with that's now that they're
doing that 10 years ago this is not what
they were teaching US 10 years ago 10
years they're pushing women to work in
this field work in that field do this do
that so right now maybe this newer
generation coming up the women have a
better chance of learning how to go back
to traditional ways than being wives
again but we went through a whole era
where women you better get up and work
because there were a lot of men that
weren't working so women better get up
and work and help the house well men
still out earn women but then again so
we go back to the childhood all right
and what parents taught us so if my mom
taught me how to cook and how to clean
and to look after the house and to paint
the wall so this kind of prepares me for
the wisiness of the situation right so
again it's not just schools it's not
universities it's not like education
system
that is fully responsible for being as
good wives or good husbands is our
upbringing where we come from and the
more we're not getting it at home the
more we are crappier right correct and
that's why it's so important for
families to stay together that's why
women should not have sold out the men
to the government
because now the next generation of women
has all these problems where we don't
know how to be wives and even above all
this stuff like what percent of women
will obey their husband
because if you want if you want to be in
a traditional marriage no it doesn't
it's not if he leads right that's not
biblical
it's not it's not submit when I feel
like it it's submit all the time and
support him even when he makes the wrong
decisions
the Titanic goes down with the the
captain you go down no but the Bible
does say that the wife should submit to
her husband but it also says that this
husband should be able to lead should be
able to actually take care of his family
so if you can't take care of your family
and I have to now go out of work what
issue you're going into is now it's oh
he's leading like when I decide he's
leaving now it's based on your feelings
that's the problem like that's why men
get frustrated when they go to church
because they go to church and women
there's not even like women that will
actually submit to their husbands and so
I'll submit when I feel like he's
leading but you're only going to do that
when you're comfortable with him think
about it so you think any man like let's
say if I started dating
um John right if I start dating John
tomorrow I I should just already be like
go ahead and leave me lead the way
everything you do I'm gonna trust in you
yes yes the whole Secret Life as a
heroin addict or something but this is
you can't get anything good going into
it
you can't go into things in bad faith
like you will never get a good outcome
if you're going into things if you're
making like the men of the the few the
your the men of the future pay for the
mistakes of your past like then there's
no future imagine if a man came to you
and it's like oh I need to go through
your phone
okay like I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
pay for dinner because you might be
talking to 10 other guys you think he's
crazy
but women will put the mistakes of their
exes on the men of their future but I
think it would be unwise for a woman to
meet a man and tomorrow be like go ahead
and lead the way you're still getting so
you're supposed to you're supposed to
have like your brothers or you're
supposed to vet him can I ask Johnny a
question because you work with men
helping them date at the you know is
that something that men generally are
one in the men you're working with for
um a woman who will obey them
I wouldn't use the word obey you know it
sounds like controlling
as I said earlier allows them to to take
the lead you know
um femininity is about receiving
masculinity is about giving
you know so just allow space for that an
example is I was speaking to a friend of
mine she went away with her friend two
girls and two boyfriends
they emptied the car they had the bags
one one of them independently just
grabbed her bags and took them straight
to the door
the other one allowed her guy to take
the bags kind of take them to the door
and the friend goes why did you let him
take the backs
because with little things like that
that I give him space to do so he he
feels like he's
he has a role in the relationship yeah I
I sort of I fear the micro things that
you know on a date yeah yeah I I
completely agree I think um that there
is a real magic that happens when you
have a relationship where a woman can be
feminine and a man can be masculine I
think that there's a real sparkle yeah
um but
I think
um
that actually
I don't well and it's a question I have
really it's just that from my experience
if I'm dealing with a man who is phoning
over me and would obey my every command
like I would think he was pathetic and
disgusting so he obey you I said you're
supposed to obey him no I know but I'm
just saying like I I personally feel
like men and women that we are different
but I don't think that I can not
empathize with men at all and I feel
like wouldn't
um I don't know the kind of men that I
would want to be with you know sort of
high intelligence very interesting kind
of guys I would think that they would
lose respect for me if I you know flatly
obeyed without any kind of challenge you
know for me I think that a relationship
should be you should be challenging each
other to be the best versions of
yourself absolutely to grow and yeah and
if that if that means that on you know
in an appropriate way
on you know on appropriate occasions a
wife has to tell her husband I think
you're taking the wrong course of action
I think you know you could behave in a
way that's more effective that's cool
and you know a good husband would want
to hear that if it was appropriate
you're absolutely right
um one of the exercises I do with anyone
I first work with them is hash out what
they want from someone you know of
course The Superficial aspects but the
character traits and one thing that
comes up time and time again is this
word challenge that's exactly what
you're talking about it's this pushback
it keeps the respect in the relationship
it lets the other know where the line is
and what your boundaries are and I feel
and back to like one of the earliest
points we had in this conversation today
we spoke about why people leave
um I feel like people leave because they
attach so much fear
to relay in what's important to them
that they never actually have that
conversation
and they just end up getting frustrated
and then they walk but my point isn't
that you can't offer your perspective my
point at the end of the day it's his
decision that's traditional like that's
that's if we're gonna go back to like
I've read the writings of people like
100 200 years ago when they described
like real traditional relationships they
don't really exist anymore and the whole
point is like if you want to be in an
actual traditional relationship you're
supposed to obey your husband like at
the end of the day it's his decision
it's not saying like you can't give him
any input let me ask you a question do
you feel that if a woman meets a man she
should let him lead like straight off
the the gate like when do you think a
man should start leading in a
relationship instantly so you think
instantly since we go on our first date
for a couple questions you'll measure it
straight away right like is he making
the plan for the date
or is he a bit indecisive and sort of on
the fence and he's asking you're losing
attraction for him right there and then
so you're measuring from that right from
the get-go yeah okay when you say let
him lead it sounds like like you have to
allow him to
you do have to allow you you are in
control of yourself right so if I let a
man lead me that means that I'm taking
my authority conscious decision hey
whatever you say I'm going with what you
say so that's indicating on you
following like like it's so interesting
language like the way we use language
because it's like Elite like like I
think a trump like that's someone who's
like a leader like Melania doesn't let
him lead he just leads and she can
either follow or not yeah but but that's
the he but she loves to be like I don't
wanna I don't want to call her a puppet
but that's what he married he married
someone who was easy just to be like hey
I need you to be this beauty queen sit
here well look at that's what the top
men pick but we'll have it all if you
look at it yeah I'm sorry if you let me
put my my five pencil we all have roles
right and if there is a let's say let's
say family is like a company right so if
there is a boss do you obey your boss
yes you do obey your boss so if your
husband is a boss then you kind of have
to obey him anyway I have no problem
with obeying my husband and uh but I
trust him wholeheartedly so if he does
not you know if he betrays my trust then
there is other ways and repercussions
and perhaps who are not suitable or we
are discussing the situations stuff like
that but there has to be a head and I
have I have to agree with you there has
to be a head yeah to every company so if
you just say yes you know you do you
have to obey in some situations but
again we are going back to the trust and
the level being built and built and
built and working as a teamwork together
we're all different I do my bit you do
your bit and if I need to I obey you I'm
not ashamed I'm proud of it actually
because it builds our families bonds
stronger can I ask you a question Pearl
now when you meet a man right and this
two-part question when you meet a man do
you let him lead right away
do I let him later I don't think I can
let a man leave or does he lead right
away do you like follow his decisions
like right away you meet him you're like
you know what you got this yes yes okay
so if he came to you let's say
first date was November now two months
later in January he's like hey I saw
this building I think I kind of want to
buy it I want you to go in half of me
would you do it he's leading
are we married
you're letting him lead he's telling you
for our future this building's gonna be
it yeah I would say let's let's get
married and then I'll I'll go on I'll we
can go right ahead you know so you would
no you're letting him leave
you know I don't know if that's the best
example but that's what I'm saying about
my building but that's what it sounds
like when you say just let like
you have to get to know the man first
before you say okay I trust your
judgment to know that you are not going
to lead me to a path of Destruction so
you have to get to know that man you
have to know that he can lead himself
first I'm not saying like submit to any
old guy you meet like but I'm saying if
you're going on a date with him I'm
saying go in in good faith yes I'll go
on dates with good things I actually
what you said earlier I get turned off
if I if a man's supposed to take me on a
date and he comes to picks me up and he
has no plan of where we're going like
lead the way my favorite my favorite
thing to tell a guy is lead the way lead
especially on a date lead the way this
is you I'm finally behind you I'll show
you yeah I want to see because I'm I'm
ready to let a man lead I'm tired of
working um go ahead like you might have
three babies go ahead I'm ready but when
you meet these men and get like the new
age men especially in after 35 years
it's like hey so what do you want to do
what are you doing 50 50 split the bills
yeah the 50 50 so if I work at the
nursery all the time but I think
I would like money to pay 50 .
well is that common I've never really
had guys want to go 50 50. is that
common for you guys in New York no I'm
married
that's actually that's like a me thing
like I don't know when I grew up I had a
lot of like you know male friends it was
a mixed group but there were a lot of
boys and we were equal this was you know
the sort of late night early 2000s and
we were equal and so it has never
occurred to me that if I go on a date I
would do anything other than go 50 50.
it's English famous really like British
thing no I just said like if I went on a
date like I don't know but you're
talking about in your childhood that
sounded like this yes yeah yeah
um and
I don't think that that is appropriate
like I think it's appropriate if you
both decide that kids are you know what
you want in your life and you know you
want to give kids the best possible
nutrition so mum's gonna stay at home
and breastfeed them uh and unless she's
like fortunate enough to be able to earn
from home she has minimal time you know
he is gonna have to be the one providing
but like on a first date like I I don't
know I I find that quite emasculate and
it's like the idea that someone would
have to pay for the privilege of
spending time with me it's like no I
want to start out like us I've just
found that most guys like want to yeah
that's like I've never had like a guy
didn't want like I can't even yeah no I
have I have experienced like yeah
discomfort from guys like because I'm
not comfortable with them paying if you
go on like a lot I do a lot of online
dating and there are men who are like
hey if we go on a date 50 50. we can go
get a coffee but if we go on an actual
date I want to make sure I'm not wasting
my time and you're not there for a free
meal so go 50 50 with me just to prove
that you're there for the right reason
then I wouldn't go for sure
like dude really I cook amazing just
come over but it's a real thing that
this is real life like situations and
scenarios that women are going through
like even there was one guy I met nice
guy and I was like okay you know I do
want to go on a date with you and he
said just to let you know first date
we're 50 50. I said okay block like I'm
gonna block you because what are you
talking about and then he's seen me in
person I was like hey you don't remember
me I don't Mr 50 50 I don't please don't
talk to me don't try to get a dance to
me don't talk to me you're not the type
of man you want me to let you leave but
I have to pay you 50 50 on the first
date come on I had a story where um
friend of mine she went on a date and uh
had a prompt the guy to pay he said oh
okay and uh she weren't gonna go home
with him so anyway the next day he
messaged her for the money back
this is happening
I'll tell you those guys point of view
though it's because like you're not a
traditional woman right like because
over over traditional women really get
married before 25 because they spend
their most fertile years focused on
family the most traditional women want
families first right so it's not an
insult it's not a bad thing it's just
the most traditional not the bad thing
it's me yeah the most the most
traditional women get married they stay
married 25 and under I would say roughly
um so it's like they're like why am I
paying like why am I doing the
traditional thing when I don't get the
traditional outcome
but that's because it's like it's like
we wanted to be equal right we wanted to
go to work we wanted to spend our 20s in
the workforce and then we do that and
then we're like all right now treat me
traditionally and so a lot of guys are
just confused they're like I thought you
guys were modern but it's also the
evolution of mankind like a lot of
people might look at it like oh back in
the day back in the day this that like
this is the new way of doing things
Everything Has Changed nowadays so I
think that in marriages nowadays you can
have a traditional slash modern woman
because it does take some of the
pressure and strain off of the guy you
can say okay you want a traditional wife
who's going to be home have the kids not
work but do you really want that or
would you like somebody who is 65 35
with you you spend you pay 65 of the
bills I pay 35 of the bills we have the
kids do you know what traditional is
it's One bank account he controls the
money if we're really going to be
traditional but most of times right when
a man works most of the time when a man
works at a married situation he puts the
money in the bank who pays who actually
writes out the checks for the bills the
woman does that's part of her household
Duty right but but I'm saying I don't
think most relationships are traditional
nowadays so I don't think like using
modern times like you'd really have to
go back and like read like The the
history of like traditional
relationships but the man would still
make the final say on all the expenses
so if she was spending money would be
off of a budget that he signed off of or
like he told her basically yeah but
she's still the one who's dispersing the
money right she's still the one who's
like okay this has to be done he's
putting the money in the bank account
she's saying the lights are going to be
paid right but my my point is though
it's still like his decision in a
traditional relationship it's still One
bank account
like it's not her money it's the money
for the family that's traditional
because traditional is family first but
then isn't it the gate to abuse if such
occurs no
so what is the safety as Paramount
situation would if he's abusive and then
he takes away all the savings so she she
worked at home for 20 years and he
worked at 12. they have many together
and then he decides to uh Bank his
secretary right
now protections there used to be
protections for women but we wanted
equality so be equal
you know which is traditional or it's
it's
seen now as the enslavement the
financial enslavement of women
um but women did have a veto over major
financial decisions so a man couldn't
just go you know what we're selling this
family home and we're moving to another
part of the country yeah she would have
a veto
um and uh men men also
in the UK had a responsibility a legal
responsibility and could be imprisoned
if they were seen to be failing to keep
their wives and children in like a state
that was I know reasonable for the
amount of wealth that they had so if
they've got their wife and kids dressed
in rags but they're like in silk suits
but they could also go to jail if the
wife decided to just go and Splurge a
load of money run up a load of debts
that couldn't be paid back I saw the law
recently they're the the writings it was
like the one in New York where they were
talking about why they didn't want women
to vote because they were doing giving
like the the Privileges that women had
and they're saying we don't want to be
equal and one of them was like you could
um yeah you could send your husband to
jail if he wasn't taking care of you so
he literally was like yeah yeah yeah but
no no we wanted to be equal so be equal
send him on it well you know if you
don't pay child support those take you
to jail for order if you do not pay your
child support you positively will go to
jail until you have the almost like a
bailout of a minimum of what you have to
pay just to get out which you which is
needed because think about it like men
are just having babies all over the
place
women are having babies all over the
place by themselves this is no this is
again if a man's getting more than one
woman pregnant that is the women being
stupid that is and he's not being played
five stupid woman to one stupid man but
that is on the women but you gotta think
about it right now do you think a man
tells you up front everything there's so
not on so many right but there are men
who have did you introduce him to your
father did you introduce him to your
brother no no no I don't know
women will cry later when their friend
said he was toxic their dad said don't
date him here their brother said what
are you doing and then the women will
whine later about the results you can
everybody warned you no I don't believe
this whole the wool was over my eyes I
have no idea
every man I've dated that has lied to me
was because I was stupid and did not
listen to the men around me and the only
way I had better results was by
realizing that and making better
decisions but women just want to say
nothing is our fault but what if
everything is what if you have no
brothers no dad you don't have a mouth
you go to say bet this man out there
well then then you seek out males that
have your best interest at heart I know
women that have been in that situation
they get involved in a church I know
there is always a way but how do you
know what Mel is going to have the best
interest at heart how many times has a
woman been like oh this is my first age
of first marriage is 30 you got 10 years
to figure it out how would you no no
what I'm saying is that how would you
know you meet a guy okay we're gonna be
friends you're thinking this is my
friend this is my buddy has my back and
then he tries to sleep at you one day
you're like usually I would say married
couples are probably the best
well yeah but you can go to you know
your church meetings or any of these
kind of support groups that are full of
men that are in their 70s you know so
the likelihood that they're going to be
telling them
a married man's not going to try to
sleep with you as well yeah
I'm gonna hang on a minute like wow
expecting her to say wouldn't
she's giving you like five different
options but you keep asking but why but
why but why this is what I'm saying this
is discussion that is all about no no
I'm just telling you about the
psychology of it so literally women
really don't want solutions they just
want to hop on about the problem no
there is a thing there is a saying that
the most single men are married men the
most single men are married men these I
don't know you know what's a better
saying women want the married man and
they'll chase them down there's a saying
I went to a pick up a pickup like boot
camp I don't know maybe this is what you
run I don't actually know don't actually
know I I but but it was like these guys
pay to learn how to like talk to women
get laid I just like went to watch one
of the instructors said that if he wears
a wedding ring he gets more attention
from women I believe that yeah when he
has a puppy that's true pre-selection
yeah yeah so it's like I really think
this is all projection like the women
are like the married mental cheap but
it's like now we chase after the married
men and they go for it right you have
your own choice whether you're gonna go
for it or not so if you're married and
I'm chasing you and you give in is that
my fault is that your fault I'm not
remembering your vows it's like how many
people takes to get pregnant too right
so how many people's responsibility it
is no I would say it's the woman's
responsible if she gets pregnant yeah of
course I would say yes yes yes of course
it's my responsibility I choose the
partner I choose the dad for my children
or not I think until men have equal
Reproductive Rights we have to put it on
the women
you know I can't because I really
believe right if the women do nothing
about the women I think women do a lot
of things wrong but I also defend women
I also believe in defending women if
women had
in our poom pooms right that would block
off a man's sperm ever even coming
through whether we're on Earth We're
trying to have a cop no like things
happen you know my favorite say goodness
things happen right let's say let's say
women wear condoms or like require the
men that sleep with them wear condoms I
mean if we
the point that I'm trying to make is
this right the point I'm trying to make
is if we had something in our bodies
right that would say I don't want to get
pregnant at this time like we had like a
door that could just stop around it's
called ovulation you can track when
you're ovulating but what I'm saying
something we had yeah if we had this in
our bodies right we just I mean this is
where I'm just making up a scenario
right if we had this in our body less
women would get pregnant because think
about it science is not always
guaranteed right you can be on birth
control get pregnant oh I missed the
pill day got pregnant oh the birth
control didn't work there's so many
reasons why women could get pregnant
right even if you track ovulation all
that if we had something in our body
after we've had while we're having sex
with these men and they're about to go
ahead and come out and we have blockers
like blockers less women would be
pregnant girl because girl we got Plan B
where is the excuse when you have okay I
can tell the guys I can track when I'm
ovulating then I can tell the guys that
I sleep with to wear condoms then on top
of that I can take a plan B on top of
that I can get an IUD on top of that I
can get on the pill
um so on top of that I can get an
abortion it's like okay so what so I'm
just say these five things right what if
you don't believe in abortion right so
that enhances abortion what if you can't
get on birth control because it messes
with your system makes you bleed you get
fat like that messes you up right what
if you are allergic to condoms right
what if a guy says but I pulled out and
you didn't and he didn't pull out what
if you don't have money to afford a plan
B like there's so many different
situations that real life situations
people go through what they don't know
about abstinence is for you
[Laughter]
I just think it's time to close the legs
at this point I think it would be easier
for the men to have a device in their
wallet that stops the government from
reaching into their wallet to take money
that will stop the problem don't worry
man can happen less women will have
babies if the government couldn't take
money from the men men can have ai
though all that speaks to them and hugs
them and it's coming soon everything
it's coming soon see the biggest yeah
literally you're as smart and that will
be the end of humanity you're a smart
educated woman so you know about all
this stuff there's so many women who
come up the households okay okay I wanna
I wanna teach you something okay I want
I want King could you please um put the
internet up on the screen I'm just going
to show you this really great like
what is this thing what you call the
internet
wait wait wait wait wait I need you to
wait okay can you put type in google.com
please please type in google.com
not just just in case anyone else
wait wait Google
now could you put in birth control
methods please
thank you there you go just in case
anyone but this group without but this
is okay you can take it off but guess
what this is again if you have the
resources for that if you have the
resources to afford the internet if you
have access
of people
have a smartphone
how many have a smartphone let's do you
you want to do us or UK it doesn't
matter worldwide okay um I'm gonna do
the us because I don't think worldwide
would be a fair comparison
um you know
what what percent would you say there's
not really an excuse okay what percent
of people what what number would maybe
change your mind that everyone has a
choice in this
don't choose better especially women
they just keep making the same mistakes
over and over again some of us do some
women definitely make the same okay
that's right for love okay so so what
percent of people do you think own a
smartphone
I don't know maybe 60
92 of people own okay so now we have
zero is this is this is this from
okay but this is a certain demographic
that you are no because it's just across
the please nope just across the board
I'm looking at if I go right to my
neighborhood right now maybe 60 of
people might own a phone a smartphone
they'll own a phone they have Obama
phones which don't have internet they
have free stuff
were you saying in the black community
is that what I'm I'm not trying to say
that okay because I looked that up it's
80 it is a little lower it is lower so
again yeah but they've all got a friend
who they can go look I'm really
concerned about getting pregnant can I
borrow your phone to look up but you
have control methods but you have to you
have to know yeah you have to know how
to do that like do you believe in
empowering women
are smart of course okay so don't okay
so now because you're treating us like
we're dumb no I'm not treating women
like they're dumb I used to be a social
worker so there's certain things that
you're gonna say you used to be a woman
no no I used to be a social worker so
there's certain things when you come
across certain people you talk with them
and you're like wait you didn't know
what into to like someone like me I'm
like impossible but there are really
people in circumstances and situations
that just don't know they never had
someone to tell them to teach them if
you're somewhere and you go to a rough
school and no one's taught you this no
one's taught you that they're barely
passing you just so the school could get
funding from the government there's so
many people out there in impoverished
neighborhoods and stuff like that I
don't have access to Internet that don't
have funds for plan
you know do you know what I need I
need a soundboard that has the world's
smallest violin that place it might
sound like that but you know what it
sounds exactly until you until you
experience it until you look around and
observe it it's gonna feel unreal to you
as a person who has seen people like
this okay okay okay do you know I don't
think anybody interacts with more people
than me
no no no no no do you know how many
women have been in this apartment
yes yes just this apartment a thousand
roughly yeah in a year
so we I I don't know anybody that didn't
have a smartphone
but that's here at a particular level
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna move on
we're gonna move on
um I'm gonna read show topics or not
show topics Super Chat super chats
um and then we're gonna go back I have
another question for you guys so
um guys make sure you like the video um
how many likes are we at right now King
600. and I want to know in the chat
um do you have a smartphone one if you
have a smartphone yeah I need to I also
need a three or a four in the chat I
need a three in the chat
um if you know what a plan B is if you
know what birth control is I need a four
if you have no idea all right I'm gonna
Read Super chats
um if they are rude these are not my
opinions but I will read them Darius
lady stop kids go to school they have
computers Gore does this chick ever have
someone else to blame for her mistakes
Rex in the UK a lot of men have kids
then they become single then they go on
the Dole as unemployed they pay like 10
pounds per month per child it's
disgusting Vinnie imagine sending your
wife to jail for not having sex
um adventurous filmmaker think of Bree
van can't dump from Desperate Housewives
she's traditional but the problem is she
took the male's role by controlling the
marriage Thailand 25 Miss New York men
have been used for foodie dates in New
York City also stopped the cat there are
plenty of men of value in New York City
maybe that the ones not the ones that
are your type or in your neighborhood
um FS Claire women want uh want to
comply when it benefits them and not
when it doesn't if you did that with
your job you would be fired they don't
want to be led they want someone to lead
how they would lead and men don't lead
like women adventurous filmmaker off
topic recently watched um a Kelly
Clarkson episode advocating for women
and feminine men the media ruins
everything
exocentric nightmares the level of old
women cope on the couch is hilarious to
my UK USA brothers please do not
entertain women like this please pick
smarter and better Vinnie LT you are
what you attract and you aren't what you
reject if you friend zone a good
well-to-date new man that does well by
you for a Tyrone you don't deserve good
treatment loyalty and selection David
the Goliath women make great Housewives
said Dave
women are more compassionate than men
um because they never commit violence
like men do there will never be a female
Congress Khan
I've actually heard that women are more
um violent than men you know what it
depends on your definition
um women are significantly more likely
that victims of the elderly and babies
and children and a lot of it gets
written off you know as
freak accidents until the point where
someone goes but why is the rate so high
in this particular establishment really
oh that's so awesome yeah that's so
interesting so like well I mean it's
it's kind of profoundly disturbing I
think like you know I I find violence
generally
um frightening and scary but it's like
if it's
you know um two men or an equal number
of men who are kind of equally matched
and there's something that is you know
fair about that uh whereas yeah no women
are a sort of opportunists and it's you
know often done for like financial gain
or uh because someone is a burden there
are those kind of really so they commit
violence towards the elderly and towards
children yeah there's a book by a woman
I forget her name but it's called when
she was bad and it's really a horrible
read but yeah
it's funny enough we have the subject on
you know sometimes when we do like
social studies and we have experiments
right if a man slaps woman or yells at
her in public oh you want like jumps
into defend them and if she slaps him or
yells at him everyone's just laughing
like ah this is funny and this is not
okay but violence as you mentioned
any any violence is not okay so I cannot
just slap a man and expect not to be
slapped back because it's equally not
okay as simple as that but yeah
unfortunately I'm gonna finish these
really quick um the one in the green
that lies about her age was terrible on
King Richie's Injustice delusional here
she never lands and blames you for
taking her literally said Dave women are
more compassionate than men because they
never commit violence like men do um
there will never be a female Hitler
Genghis Khan Sid Dave um women are more
why'd you put the same
Super Chat like three times
um Boomerang Chang
um teamwork is never equal someone is
always doing a little more than all the
rest
um the leader women will never choose to
do hard jobs for long term they go to
work looking pretty not to work
um The Savvy Ninja on most jobs women
have go alongside Genesis 218 I will
make him a helpmate men and women were
never meant to be equal majority of the
responsibility falls on men as was
intended from the beginning um trucker
SMH I can't even with these women
thinking pushing papers is equally as
important as the physical label labor
required to build a house let alone
infrastructure like for real Adam Sutton
the most motivated men are those with a
wife and children at home if the men
Make the World Go Round by inspiring men
then they should get out of the
workforce
um
okay I think that's all of them so
my next question
is loving your job a privilege
would you agree with the sentiment
loving your job is a privilege not a
right
a hundred percent yeah
but actually I think um that there is a
level of ingratitude that is
um not helping people I think that
people are not sufficiently aware that
work really is a part of the human
condition that we need for its own sake
just you know to feel useful to have a
reason to get up in the morning to be
part of the team
um those things are inherently good for
us so I think maybe people complain
about jobs a little bit too much
although you know I do think there is a
toxification coming from having
too many women in the workforce I agree
with you and disagree with you loving
your job is actually a necessity because
if we love our what we do we are good at
it and we want to strive in it and we
enjoy it and as simple as that it's easy
for us to do and we can give more to the
society
it's definitely a privilege because most
people don't like where they work but if
you like you said uh if you actually
love where you work it won't feel like a
job it only feels like a job when you
don't like it so I agree it's a
privilege it's not a right you're you're
privileged to even be employed with
unemployment rate being so high you
better be blessed and thankful you even
have that job complain all you want but
you better be thankful you have it
yeah and I think um we often hear people
not enjoying their job or the workplace
the people they work with and I think
when you catch yourself in that mindset
perhaps just remind yourself what it
allows you to go away enjoy outside of
work and
you know in that sense it is a privilege
to be able to to go to work to do that
yeah there's some research that shows I
think it's seven in ten men are work
centered and so the you know
part of their life that they get the
most satisfaction from is work but that
still leaves three in ten who actually
need to work for various reasons
including psychological but there are
other parts of their life from where
they're getting more satisfaction and
then it's like for in turn women or
something like that and so you know
women are not prioritizing needing to
love their jobs
um you know some some do and that is
lovely and I think you know it is there
is so much utility in having people who
or they have a call in and they're
following their passion they really do
give so much to society but that's not
all of us and that's fine we all strive
to grow right in our personal lives and
our relationships and education in our
careers and things like that so if there
is a necessity to have a job yes I will
do any kind of work cleaning or Barista
whatever it's it's all jobs are a
wonderful thing to have but eventually I
will try to grow and develop into the
things I enjoy doing in life and I'm
good at if I have a talent in singing I
want to be a singer eventually right
so just just be yourself and grow and
give yourself time and be proud our
women advancement programs sexist
of course no I have no idea no you are
discriminating against men like
discrimination is
it's not discriminating it's just saying
hey here's a program we need more women
in this field so we offer this program
as an incentive Wow Come on why are
there no male advancement programs
Industries like only fans and models
it's called the NBA the NFL the MLB
those are no no no no I asked you I
asked you I ask you you don't answer my
question I asked you in female
dominating Industries why are there no
incentives for men to get equal pay they
were Advanced like teachers no no I was
going to say that teachers there are
there are big incentives if you are a
especially in in the black no no I asked
you about modeling and only fans that's
not the real job no I only asked you I
asked you modeling and only fans we
could do modeling that's a real job so
there are plenty of of there's no
there's no there's no incentive programs
and men make significantly less money
than women in modeling correct anything
in monetizing Beauty women kill well
think about it women in the acting field
males still dominate everything in that
so it's one-on-one entertainment field
modeling only so yeah I asked you I
asked you modeling that's what I so I
asked you in industries that are
female-led why are there not incentives
how many men want to model how many
women
I don't know but but how many women want
to be Engineers we could do the same
thing but no so I think a lot of men
would love okay okay guys guys
I'm just curious
or random four random guys if you guys
could just take pictures for money would
you do it
I have a field modeling career so
no I I asked I asked if they got paid to
do it of course I literally said I had a
failed modeling career I'm not lying
about that yeah that's what I'm saying
I'm hiding you but what I'm saying is
that most men are not going to sit there
and be like yeah I want to be a
full-time model like they're going to
want to go
it's like it's so funny you use the same
argument like most women don't want to
be Engineers
I'm at being Engineers so I don't
want to be but if you told women if you
told more women like hey if you become
an engineer you can have a boyfriend you
really did you go after the modeling and
really if we tell both of them the same
thing they both would go for it if you
told more women you can make over 500
Grand a year just what people like to do
like in no in no industry are you gonna
get 50 50. like certain groups like
certain things based on the culture one
and two based on your gender yeah yeah
based on your gender you are going to
just like certain things like why do we
need to like fix it like why do we need
to change it like there's no law
stopping anyone from doing anything so
why do we need to encourage people to do
other things why don't they just do what
they like yeah people have nothing to
argue about but that's the thing you've
got to remember growing up you did not
see women in wrong wrong it's so wrong
because in the media that's all we have
like watch any TV show It's Always a
Woman doing a job that she would never
in never do like you have all these
women and these CEO know look at the
media the last 50 years it's all women's
empowerment the last 50 years
yeah I'll tell you something when I was
young you know what I saw things like
Married with Children right stay at home
mom
every single family everything shows
Homer Simpson he's the stupid dad the
smart mom Family Guy the stupid dad the
smart mom but and they'll still show
that dad's going to work and mom is kind
of a homemaker but they always paint the
dad is dumb and the woman knows
everything I I'm saying like the media
like why are we trying to push people
when there's no barriers anymore people
do what they want to do so why do we
need to change it people do and why do
and why like don't feminists and women
like yourself have the same energy for
the men and female oriented careers I
had the same energy
listen if I grow up right growing up
what the what do they encourage women to
do be a teacher be a doctor these are
Fields they encourage you to do now with
women advancement programs they're now
saying we don't have to keep telling you
go for these same five jobs there are
other jobs out there you guys can go for
and the women say no thank you still not
I mean it depends yes not all the time
if you exactly if you sit there and tell
somebody right if I come from a poor
householder you sit there and tell me I
could make 500 Grand a year let's say as
a engineer guess what I'm doing signing
up for the first engineer class right
yeah but you know what else you're doing
after you've got into the engineer class
and maybe you know spent a lot of
taxpayers or parents money or whoever
like whatever you are meeting a guy
there who's so amazing and you're
getting married and you're dropping out
of the workforce so you've just wasted
your time
in Canada
no it's it's just sort of you know quite
an artistically common thing in Canada
they talked about it they can't pay
women um Jordan Peterson talks about how
you would coach women to get more money
they could not pay female lawyers to
stay because they would hit 30 they'd be
on track to be partner and they would
say you know what I want to go home so
it's like why are we forcing women and
encouraging women to do things that are
not good for us we know it's not good
for us to work the same way men do so
it's like if anything I actually think
it's really unkind to women to push us
into these fields that we will want it's
going to affect our relationships
because we become too masculine and two
and two we we don't like those jobs so
we go into the jobs because the
society's pushing us into a job we don't
even want we do it and just like the
girl that went through the engineering
degree and what she do she dropped out
or she um she quit later whatever so my
favorite thing is Devil's Advocate if
you guys can tell right so my rebuttal
to that because I love a good rebuttal
is
it came and it went that fast it came
and went that fast it must not have been
that good then no it was a good thing we
were just getting tired no it was it was
a good rebuttal I promise you it was a
really good rebuttal about women going
in you can bring it up in the comments
section it'll come back it'll come back
uh one second
okay so 48 of women in the U.S were
unmarried as of 2021 only 39 of women
without children say they want to be
married that number jumps to 51 for
women with children 63 percent of women
pulled in 2022 say they don't want
children
what essential things do women bring to
society as a whole that don't have to do
with kids in child rearing
okay
um I love this little book by Roger
screw and it's called a short
introduction to beauty and he says that
there are three ultimate virtues truth
and goodness are the first two and you
know I think personally based on the
Canon of you know literature and
psychology and all of this kind of stuff
that men are absolutely excellent at
truth and goodness to be honest
um but
the third virtue is Beauty and what
Roger does he points out that you know
even when we were living in these
societies where we had issues with
scarcity you know we would still
plow all of these resources into
building these monuments or churches
these beautiful buildings the Coliseum
because we it's it's human nature to it
we need Beauty it makes the world better
and you know that is how men do it they
make these enormous awesome structures
but the way women generally tend to do
it is in little modest ways we're
attending our Gardens we're making our
homes attractive we are making ourselves
attractive we're doing little
handicrafts which are kind of modest and
they're not going to last a hundred
thousand years whatever but they make
everyday life for everyone who is in
contact with them a little bit more
beautiful and I think that's meaningful
do you think that the average woman
today is doing that
yeah
who is the average woman I don't know I
mean that's 170 pounds I'll give you
some number the average woman's 170
pounds um she's about five four ninety
percent of us have been on birth control
one out of three is an STD uh one out of
Threes had an abortion
um 50 will have zero children
um and makes about I'm just giving you
numbers here so I'm not I'm not even
trying to add a moral thing
um and makes roughly like 25 to 35 000.
I mean you know what you know what I my
in my experience when I was at school
what I was getting were all these
messages about like you should be like
you could be an astronaut you could be
the Prime Minister you should really
concentrate on all this stuff and I
think that I think that women are pushed
into being mediocre man whereas you know
we're not given the space an opportunity
to actually just express our own
femininity yeah no I I agree with you I
agree and disagree again
I'm going to read the question just one
more time what essential things do women
bring to society as a whole that don't
have to do with kids and child rearing
uh
smart it's actually it's very
interesting makes me think essential and
it it's essential to think yes no no I'm
saying essential is the keyword
essential things
I have two children but if I didn't have
any by now I wouldn't have any but not
because I'm a bad woman or I'm a bad
person or a bad female is because
Society is going to shed and look at
around the world what is happening the
force of US Financial forcing us into
jobs we don't want to do whether it's be
too male for me or whether it's just
something I'm not good at so I don't
know it's really hard to answer but it's
not just women's Choice it's a society
and the world where it's going the worse
the pressures the fake news the all the
lies we're told on the media and like
you know the bigger the more beautiful
which is not true if we're gonna hurt if
you're gonna die from a heart attack the
biggest not beautiful you're just
killing yourself and you're telling
young girls who are looking at you to
kill yourself too the biggest thing that
women bring is love
is love I know it sounds so simple but
think about it right you're having a bad
day you get a man you get hit in the
face you get punched you get jumped you
get whatever who's the first person you
go to your mother a woman right for love
for reassurance for smarts if there's a
situation where two men are about to
fight right sometimes you'll get a woman
a woman to be like hey babe don't do
that let me calm you down so the wisdom
and the love that women bring to society
just in general is very much needed I
I'm sorry I don't want a whole bunch of
men going around like just sensitivity
yeah like just in a work field not doing
anything because everything would be so
Cutthroat sometimes you need a woman to
be like hey should we really fire him
let's think about it not let's fire him
because he pissed me off like there's
certain things that you need women for
you need that balance okay let's
you know damn well women no no you know
damn well women fire people for no
reason men want to make money women men
are logical women go based on how they
feel so this idea that women are going
to come into the workforce and police
men and how to behave when man built the
world for us they built the world we
could not do any of the jobs that
we have are all because of men and that
we need women's wisdom to run Society
yes is the dumbest I've ever heard
in my life
exactly it's not it's all the elements
why the last hundred before the last
hundred years they did not need women as
a rule in the workforce why do they need
us now they must have waited women or
else we wouldn't be yeah
if you look at like government
regulations as soon as women enter the
work for course it's like it's through
the roof if you look at government
spendings as soon as women got to vote
it's like it's through the roof so would
you have rather be like like how
workforces were back in the day I would
rather we repeal the 19th I really
believe that I think the world would be
a better place if women didn't vote and
most men I think that should be just
like a property owner type thing it's or
or net taxpayers I don't know how
exactly I do it but yeah I think we
should take away the vote for most
people listen when we let the majority
of men vote they voted Trump into office
so and thank you guys thank you I like
trying I like him I like him as a person
I think he's funny horrible president
but I like him as an individual he was a
good president the economy was way
better it kind of he was better the
economy was better but he also caused uh
no no the economy was better but doesn't
mean he's a good president because under
him there was so much racial divide and
tension and this going on not going on
so whatever economy okay but you divided
jobs
and they hated each other but this is
what I mean
I actually want to explain this to the
camera like how women think no offense
but like do you see how she's like well
it was the tension we didn't like the
tension or the feelings and the men it's
like well Arthur jobs
Obama cleaned it up no it wasn't it
rolled into it got into office enrolled
into someone got into office and Trump
got the credit for it no it wasn't
that's true the Liberals try to like try
to they'll try to like like somehow go
through these like logic Loops where
they're like well it was good under
Trump's presidency but it was another
president's fault like it's like come on
yeah do you realize I had an economics
degree and so what specifically what
policies from Obama specifically there
is so specifically right now I can't
think of it off the top of my head but
they're like literally but but again we
studied this when I was
eight years in office but it is during
Trump's time that you felt the effect of
his yes because when he first got it
when he first got it no no when he first
got in office they kept denying
everything he tried to put in what what
are they trying what are they every time
what the difference
what Bill what bill I believe the first
one was one of the health care books
before we finally got that what did it
do I would even say Trump had a harder
time in office than Obama yeah because
no one liked him exactly but he still
got things done what done what do you
mean what's done
unemployment is through the roof right
now under Biden it's undivided which
rolls off of what happened with Trump
I'm telling you everything is a is an
effect you can go ahead and try to put a
bill into office if it does not get into
office and it keeps going through the
house keeps going keeps going now
you start to see the effects of policies
fairly quickly we went over this when I
was in school like I have a degree in
economics like you start to see you
start to see the effects of policies
fairly quickly like within a couple
months
that's not true that's not true but what
do you think what do women bring to
society that is essential yeah I agree
with love
um other words that come to me uh
sensuality and Sensitivity I heard just
then as well
um you know and sensuality can be
anything like
you know the appreciation of of your
daily activity as a beautiful flower
there's some amazing architecture just
tuning into that frequency that
emotional frequency that I think a lot
of men don't tend to normally have you
know I think the argument here is about
the argument we're having here a lot of
your responses have been emotional
right and but that is a beauty in that
as well because we can we can take that
on board
in a positive way
what
um okay
how
so in the jobs that we listed earlier
that men perform vehicle technician
Carpenters electricians metal workers
plumbers machine drivers forklift
drivers vehicle delivery drivers on-site
construction workers and Village window
fabricators
how long do you think you would work in
any of the 10 jobs
listed that men perform
I wouldn't because it's not my thing to
do yeah is that like I can pick any one
of them I can't yeah so like yeah how
long you think you would last before you
had uh you had to cut
I mean you know it kind of depends on
like the scenario like I'm quite into
the idea of a zombie apocalypse and I
reckon I could you know like if I really
needed it too but if you're if you're
asking me like you know I've I've got a
choice here I can carry on leading the
life I do live in which I sacrifice the
amount of money that I'm able to earn in
order to be able to work from home for
five days a week nine to five and manage
my own time because I have other
priorities
um so yeah if I have a choice that is
not something difficult then I'm not
doing something difficult now I think
I'd last six months
yeah I think then I would quit I would
last as a plumber I would be gone one of
the things I'm into though I'm into
building I'm into doing this so that's
stuff I wouldn't mind I do my own DIY
and like if there's you know a sink
that's blocked I can deal with that
myself I keep doing it then
why don't I do well no I am doing it at
home because the lady that likes me I'm
sorry why am I not building because I
work a job where I'm able to make money
to travel the world because that's what
I want to do right now I want to travel
I'm trying to work on my acting I'm
trying to do this and do I know so if
you can that's why I'm not but guess
what if I had money if I had the what
did I say the other day I want to go
into mechanic school because I want to
learn how to fix cars this is stuff that
I'm genuinely it's survival I'm sorry I
have a survival mentality so these are
things I actually want yeah if you want
the zombie movies as well
yeah yeah what's your what's your day
job uh bartending
and we make tips so I make a lot of
money and then you say okay do you see
the
the disconnect from what you're on
Survival but your job is a bartender
yeah but if you need to survive you do
what you need to do right exactly I
bartend at night I work on sets during
the day yeah there's nothing wrong
there's nothing wrong with that but I'm
saying that's not like what you're
saying you like to build things but that
that is what I do they like to talk no
when which is a way I like to talk to
you that's why I do what I do I actually
like to build things like I literally
sit at home like when I let's say move
something breaks I will fix it that's
things that I actually like when things
go wrong I will fix stuff yeah that's
something if you actually dedicated time
to becoming a builder you make way more
money and a way better career than
what's your but I'm trying to do right
now I would have to always work I just
said you love building I would have to
always work though right I would have to
always be at work right I don't I'm a
person who I like Freedom right so my
job gives me freedom I could take off
whenever I can do it I don't have to
come in for a month if I don't want to
that's the type of freedom I like if I
could be a builder right and still make
the same amount of money a year but only
come in half the year why wouldn't I do
it
I don't have the same luxury of what you
just said
as in as a as what I can't I can't
choose a job where I can just get up and
go whenever I want why can't you there's
a whole bunch of centers I work with
they do the same thing they travel the
country singing this is why we say women
can never understand the disconnect
between women and men
just like obviously I'm doing a job I
enjoy I'm doing a job I love and I
appreciate having this kind of job most
people are not even in the position I'm
in right now but I still can't just get
up and go whenever I want
because of the responsibilities that I I
have yeah you plan around obviously if
you want a construction job tell me I
have connections
but that's the thing you're saying you
don't have the luxury because again that
is the job that you chose I chose a job
that gave me those luxuries it's because
no the reason why I don't have the
luxury to get up and go is not really
about the job it's about the goals I
have for my life so if I if I were to be
getting up and going whenever I wanted
to or whenever I felt like I am
literally putting stops on my way to
getting to where I need to be in life
but why is that I have goals right I'm
sitting here in a podcast which is
networking right which is wow look at
everything my goals like every
successful person that has made any
amount of money that you can ever be
proud of or say this is this is a good
body of work they never had the luxury
to get up and go whenever they wanted
but we're saying again women should be
you know why I'm saying teachers
think like that and that's why men are
where they are and because men would
really literally work 80 hours a week to
get to where they need to get to but who
says that I don't sit with them at work
I
right so instead of working seven days a
week right instead of working one job
seven days a week I'll work two jobs
four days a week same thing right
putting I'm putting the same time in and
this is this is literally what I do and
you know what I do with my off time I go
to try to further what I'm getting into
right I'm trying to move to the UK soon
so what am I doing making a name for
myself in the UK I'm still furthering my
career we're doing the same thing we're
just taking different routes to do it if
a man decides that he needs to work 80
hours a week to further himself that's
on him I chose a job that's going to
give me the luxury to do what I need to
do for myself that works for me
so tomorrow is your first the tomorrow
is your first day on the building site
how long is it going to be till you're
back doing what you're doing now
I think that's what the question isn't
it is what if I start working on that
distraction how long do you think you'd
last in a construction job
what is it you get two weeks out of
vacation three weeks vacation a year
maybe what what are the wages so this is
no this is how I would think about it I
would literally think about it like okay
if I work a construction job for five
years right I'll work that job make
enough money to build my own okay
whatever company or whatever like that
and now start another business from
there that's how my five years
five years to make enough money okay to
have my own business last five years no
she's staying and she's staying in the
industry industry yeah but she's in for
life she's starting tomorrow and I'm the
next like Trump yeah it's gonna be a
store next door they're building a
building I'll sign you up you can move
to the UK I promise if they give me a
Visa I promise I'll move here tomorrow
and start building you can get a
master's degree you can get a Visa you
know you can marry me instead there we
go you can you can't have it you can't
get a Visa through a master's degree
though just so you know that's what here
yeah you get it with a two-year Visa or
a two-year degree now you can get a
master's degree in a year one year and
then get a Visa at the end and they'll
give you a Visa indefinite Visa yeah
it's like uh two years or something
no like you get a work visa once you
graduate
okay and that's what I'm saying here or
back in America no UK so do you want to
move to the UK okay so just apply for
school yeah okay I already have a
bachelor yeah so that's what I did yes
thank you that was one of the best
advice I've ever had so far I appreciate
it yeah yeah so Sisterhood yeah how long
how long do you think you would have you
ever worked construction any blue collar
it's too good looking for that you know
when I was younger like Saturday jobs
and stuff like this oh yeah how long do
you think you could have worked a
construction job
not very long to be honest I mean um I
don't find joy in it I get stimulation
through the practicality of it yes but I
mean
you know I went to study engineering you
know that so it's similar but I quickly
realized I want to get my hands dirty
for the rest of my life
so how long
a year a year yeah
I said I had six months I was like I
couldn't be me
I'm like you're a good looking man of
course you're not doing construction
come on it's not a construction phase
we're gonna do one one more question
then we're gonna close out the show
all right if a man were to get a maid a
prostitute and a cook
what would the man need a woman for
hmm
to cuddle
[Laughter]
to listen to him and to speak to him and
to be a companion
and to grow together that's the
prostitute
[Laughter]
tonight I'm sorry I'm not too involved
in the business
yeah what what services is he buying is
it the girlfriend experience yeah this
is a high-end prostitute
this is like the the epitome well I
don't know I mean like maybe perhaps his
wallet is getting a bit heavy so we
could get a woman in to help him lighten
the load a bit oh she like she could
work
spend his money like he's actually
physically struggling yeah it's
obviously Rich he's got a maid of
prostitute on girlfriend experience
oh okay so yeah he just needs a woman in
there what was that phrase you used
earlier dispersing the money I love that
that is so women like just dispersing
the money I'm going to the High Street
money just pass it's like confetti isn't
it beautiful
so what would you do to compete so you
go you I know this is a hypothetical
he's got all those things what are you
like what are you gonna do to like this
is your dream guy no I I want to be
doing those things for a man I love so
if I went and you know I loved a man and
he had a prostitute and a maid and a
cook and he was like I'm happy with them
if you can add more then come in I'd be
like no I want to do those jobs I'll go
and find some man who wants me only yeah
let your man leave he wants his
prostitutes
I'm challenging him
uh what about you
um so if a guy has
um what what can a woman bring if he has
a maid a prostitute to cook yeah I think
I answered this all the things to do
with the emotion and emotional side and
support and friendship and companionship
and uh actually telling him yes I agree
with you or no I disagree with you and
let's build this path together
simple as that but um teamwork
absolutely everything's to do female or
male is everything to do with the
teamwork a family especially a family I
could give you a family I can make this
house a home I'm also your outlet
because men get frustrated Who you gonna
turn to hey
you don't have to pay to come on my
shoulder and cry I'm here for you Baby
I'ma be your backbone I think everybody
needs a backbone so if I could ask you
that as a woman hey let me do it and if
you get paralyzed I will tell this and I
will look after you because this is what
family is for what do you think listen I
know guys that live like that and um
you know for me it's it's
you can have these people in your life
but it's not authentic the connection's
not authentic you mentioned
companionship it's it's it's chemistry
it's open heart relating with someone
and and when you've got that with a with
a woman that
it's amazing you know
can I say one thing I do remember my
rebuttal
when you were like oh lawyers you know
you can't pay a woman to after 30 to
stay in the work field right yeah and it
all comes down to society it's a true
point that yes we had this discussion
that when the older woman is when she
has a baby the more likely fertility
goes down the baby could come out with
you know all types of issues and stuff
like that so women do leave the
workforce at 30 because Society puts
that pressure on them to say you need to
be married have your children and all
that by at least 35. Society does not
tell you that biology does yeah you're
at risk for geriatrics yeah societies go
in like they're doing everything they
can to help with this issue but Society
gives you free Mother Nature's kind of
cruel Society gives you free birth
control and abortions so I I don't think
Society
the resources into IVF and you know
facilities
the funny thing is if a woman and it's
well and it's also you have less sexual
market like you you're less um
attractive to guys the older you are I
mean that just is what it is
like you're I think women I think women
age uh beautifully I think that's how
you look after yourself yeah
your options the dating app data is
really clear it's it's half of your
options are gone by 30 from the time
you're 18 to 30. what's half of your
options I think that that women can age
beautifully but like you know you don't
stay as hot do you and and even and even
uh yeah
even just from a fertility point of view
if you're if you're 35 you're hitting
geriatric pregnancy most of the time IVF
fails so even if you do IVF after the
age of 35 it's probably gonna fail so
this idea that we like sell women like
we yeah I really don't see I really
don't see that they say have all your
together by 35 if anything they lie
to us and say you have all the time in
the world when you don't if you if
you're single by 30 as a woman you are
more likely to not ever get married or
have children than to get married and
have children
well that's depressing the more speaking
the more I think I'm a man no but I
think about I think nowadays the society
is letting you like with people like
Janet Jackson and who else just had a
baby old like they're they're starting
to show us that by 50 you can still
conceive no but celebrity but
celebrities why would you want
celebrities are not you though or
they're not the average person yeah so
it's like we'll look at JLo and be like
JLo got married at 50 but you're
not JLo but you know what I mean it's
like it's like like the average chick is
not gonna have JLo results right the
average chick is not gonna have these IV
athletes you have no idea we we have
celebrities that come out all the time
and say they couldn't have children like
Jennifer Aniston yet we still focus on
the ones that could when really maybe we
should put Jennifer Aniston as the face
of the ones that couldn't That Couldn't
yeah I mean it's one of those things
where Society is trying to tell us now a
woman you can freeze your age you could
do this if you really want to have you
know children Society has to pick do you
want us to be traditional or do you want
us to be no the women have to pick
because the women have all the power we
have the most sexual leverage first so
we're born with with I don't know a
beauty right we have Beauty fertility
youth men have to become the things that
are valuable to US money status looks I
mean look I mean looks is but getting
like a woman can just be thin and have
an amazing body a guy has to work years
to get a good body right lift do all
that stuff and so it's like women if we
we have to go first because we're the
ones that have to get married young then
we have to stop making women feel bad
for whatever decision they make if you
stop making women feel like you can't
make it you can't make anybody feel
anything like like Shaman comes from
within like I think shame comes I think
I think shame comes from God I actually
don't think nobody can make anybody feel
shame you either say things and you feel
a certain way or you don't but think
about it most people don't like to be
judged right the average person doesn't
like to be judged it makes them feel
some type of way so to duck judgment
what do you do you do things that you
may not want to do or that you you know
feel like you have to do just so you
won't be judged we lived in a
judgment-free no I I actually women
women respond really well to social
shame I actually think we need more
judgment not less and I think it would
protect women in the long run because we
see the rate of women on antidepressants
over the age of 45 if you don't have
children it's like one in three are on
antidepressants the results of women
that like when we're we have when we're
more promiscuous and we end up alone
it's negative for women but the problem
is we have no social shame or stigma
from women sleeping around and making
poor choices that result in US single
and and I actually think women respond
very well women have shown that they
respond very well to social shame but
they sit there and they try to make a
woman feel like you're not a woman or
they they give The Narrative of you're
not a woman you're not good enough of a
woman if you don't have a kid if you
don't have a family that's what you were
put here for instead of just being like
well Choice what's your choice do you
want a kid everybody everybody has a
choice but I do think over a certain age
if you don't have children like the
world kind of will ask you why and but
why is that right though
it's about gay couples
that's not about right or wrong it's
about the way like it you know we can
call we can say it's not right but the
fact of the matter is people will look
at you a certain way as a woman if you
don't have kids by a certain age so we
all brought that we gotta stop no I
disagree because I don't think it's good
for Society for women to not have
children and it's not good for women
it's not good for us oh I guess if we're
trying to get back to being feminine
yeah but not everybody we could go we
could go for two two results here we
could say what's good for society
children
replacing the population that's good for
society or if we want to be conditional
or if we want to be completely selfish
let's just say okay let's do what's good
for us as women and it shows that we're
more likely to be depressed if we have
more sexual partners we're more likely
to I can't remember all the stats off
the top of my head but it's like we're
more likely to be depressed we're more
likely to have all of these issues the
more sexual partners we have and if we
don't have a family over the age of 45
we become very depressed and the data is
super clear on this now what I believe
what about men if they have more sexual
partners they also get but the
difference the difference well no woman
because man is a hero but there's not
there's not the same repercussions for
men and for women because men care about
women's body count women don't typically
care about men's body yeah
so I saw some interest in research that
was measuring like different hormones
and responses in men and women and they
did find that when a man and woman like
sleep together like first time they've
met there is like this oxytocin like
love response from the woman that isn't
from the man where the man's like
oxytocin starts to grow where love
starts to develop is when a woman is in
his company getting to know him for
weeks on end and you know like I think I
I yeah shame is absolutely a useful
human adaptation and that's why we've
still got it but actually I think we
could start with just giving women
proper information like I mean you know
I think that so many young women are
just given this message you know the
empowerment is walks and that there
are no consequences and that that's just
a clump of cells if you want to get rid
of it get rid of it and you will never
have any second thoughts about it
definitely I think if we just have like
Frank and honest conversations we might
be able to help women to make the right
choices for them I don't think there's
any shame with like women getting to 50
and not having a child if that's their
decision like you know there are women
who genuinely like they have different
life goals they cannot have
um but when it's the case that actually
they've just been misguided they've been
told that they didn't need to rush
they've been told that they should focus
on their career and they get to 50 and
they go oh my god I've made really bad
decisions that have got me to a place
where I've got like half of my life to
live regretting the fact that I didn't
well you know sort out the family that's
just really sad you know 80 of women
that don't have kids wish they had them
yeah exactly yeah and so it's like I
just you know when you when you hear
from them they were lied to that is the
issue
uh King
um can you pull up the super chats my
laptop died I don't think my charger how
interesting why cannot older women adopt
children and have a family
that more women probably might want to
adopt because honestly child brain hurts
well it's a painful thing and it hurts
but it's a beautiful magical experience
I think it's selfish as a single woman
to adopt you're gonna put your kid at
every statistical disadvantage because
you want a kid instead of letting that
kid grow up in a two-parent household
like why would you choose that it's not
necessary she's single she's just older
because she was focusing on the career
she has to pay 55 minutes if she's if
she's if she's married then I think
that's one thing but I also think like
most men want a wife for kids but do you
know what it's kind of like what do they
get out of it let me say this adoption
is imperative do you know what kids go
through in the foster care field you
know I actually I do because um I've
been on both ends of adoption where my
parents they gave up one of my brothers
and they actually adopted a different
one so we've actually been on both ends
um so because one brother my parents
gave up when um my mom was 17 same
parents but they gave them a up for
adoption I met him when I was 22 grew up
with a completely different family and
we also adopted teenagers that were in
the foster care system that the problem
is not giving up kids for adoption it's
actually if you give an infant up for
adoption you're most likely going to
find a family that wants to adopt them
the issue is these crackhead moms will
keep the kid for like five years and the
government will take them and now what
what parent is going to want a kid
that's been basically yeah it's
up because by the time they're three
they're brain mentally development and
I've been on both ends like they um I
know a couple that adopted two brothers
one brother was five one brother was
like two or one and a half when they
adopted him the older brother it was
like they couldn't even though they're
super nice parents like he was too
developed and like he ended up stealing
from them he always in and out of
trouble the younger brother was like a
musical genius I actually so it really
just depends on the age so I actually
straight out of college that was my
first job right foster care a social
worker right case manager or whatever
that grew up with the foster care we
always adopted different family members
of Like grew up in this around the scene
stories and all that it is imperative
for adoptions to happen because when
people give up these kids these same
crackhead moms whatever like that these
kids when they're not adopted whether
it's about a single woman or not they go
through the system they jump from home
to home a lot of them are beaten molest
uh essayed all types of things happen to
them just from being in the in the
system right so I would rather a kid be
adopted by a single woman than to be in
the system messed up now growing up with
a mental health mental health issues
because they've been bounced around from
time to time but typically but typically
like in the situations I've seen the
single women typically want young
children and I think in that situation
it's quite I I just think it's quite
selfish to like pick to have a kid at
every statistical disadvantage when it
should be in a two-parent household if
you could give up I I understand like
giving them love and sure like maybe for
the kids that have nowhere else to go
but I I just think if you're gonna take
a baby where it they could be in a
two-parent household I think it's better
to be in a two pair a household I don't
know why you would bring them up in a
situation where they're at a
disadvantage and there's so many two
parents that want to adopt but taking a
kiss so infants are the high like that
that's the most requested because again
you can mold that and fit into who you
need them to be there you know I mean
sort of my brother was still pretty
similar to us even though I didn't meet
him until I was 22. no but but it's like
working it like they let you know that
like most people are going to go for an
infant right it's so harder to it's hard
to place older kids because like you
said they're developing it right whoever
they are but it's still like if it's
whoever it still just get the kids out
of there kids don't ask to be here but I
I think the better solution is for women
to get married and stay married
because that's where you're seeing a lot
of these there there are a lot of men
women are too picky that's the problem
you have average overweight women the
average woman's 170 pounds it's
overweight fat and yet they think they
deserve like men that make a lot of
money
they the average woman's had over over
10 Partners they're like this is based
on different studies
no average that which so they don't
bring Purity anymore they don't bring
youth average bride is 31. so 90 of your
dogs are gone by 31. yeah a woman stand
as a question when you're younger you
want this whole list when you get older
you realize you need to chop that list
down right yeah because they have to but
there still has to be enough men for
these women there has to be enough men
that fit the criteria for these women as
far as again one out of three one out of
three men are either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past year so they're
single men but having sex doesn't mean
that you're not in a relationship look
at Sierra and Russell Wilson they didn't
have sex so they were they didn't have
Russell didn't have sex they waited till
marriage right that's fine though that's
fine then get there but that's what I'm
I'm saying I just don't there's no
excuses I just don't like the excuses
women are the ones pushing off marriage
because men will always want young women
they're biologically even just from a
smell test like men are biologically
predisposition predisposition to like
young fertile women so if when the men
are looking for wives the the young
women don't want to get married because
women have the most power when they're
young and we choose to not get married
till we're older our young men looking
for these young women or is it older men
looking for these young people you can't
but you can't both yeah
but you can't you can always date older
women you have the most you have the
most sexual power when you are young as
a woman but most women right when
they're in a relationships and they're
waiting when most women are in a
relationship right and they're waiting
for their man to ask them to marry them
what is the most common uh excuse I have
to get myself together first I need to
make sure Finance
that's the woman's choice though because
she could date older when you were young
you can date older and if you don't
choose to that's
exactly but at 25 our other 25 year old
men ready to get married
so date 35 year old man like I just
can't but just it has to be like it's
not excuses it's real life because then
more women
my problem is but but the question is
okay if you have a product if you're a
company and you're selling a product and
nobody's buying the product do you blame
the customer or do you fix the product
you fix the product okay so why is it
with men we'll blame them for not
wanting to get married instead of fixing
the product which is humans so if you
fix yourself up even if you could be the
best woman there is if a man is not
ready he's not ready you cannot make it
and I agree and I agree with you and I
agree with you but that goes back to our
decision making
we will stay with a guy for well we'll
pick a guy and said I want I will make
you into a husband when he's clearly not
a husband and then complain about the
results
like you said you dated a criminal yes
like the criminal's not a husband that's
not husband material
okay right right it might have been
wrong so but was he a criminal because
he was trying to make money to provide
for the family if you're trying to make
money to provide for the family yes you
had to take an illegal right but if
that's all the work that there was
around for you I can't make this up
no but but this is real life this is
real life we're not going off of
Statistics
okay but I'm saying so don't whine later
because what women will do is they'll
date the the drug dealers the bad boys
in our 20s and then come in our 30s and
say to the men oh please now I want the
nice guy well but when you had the most
options and you had the most Beauty the
most youth the most Purity you picked
the bad guys and then you want the nice
guys to take you later but even if
that's the but even if you've picked the
the right guys right when I was dating
right I'm 37 now so when I was 25 there
were men that I was dating good jobs
good and I would be like yo I want to
get married what was the response
were you raised to be a wife yes I was
raised to be a wife yes okay so what
what skills do you have that are like
wife
because the whole show you've been
talking about how you were raised to
work which is fine I'm not I'm not even
like judging you about it but it's
possible that maybe they just didn't see
you as wife material I was raised so
my mother never worked okay so my mother
taught instilled in me okay you have to
cook for your husband okay I did cook
most of the family meals growing up you
have to cook for your husband you have
to make sure you serve him first before
you and your brother eat he will eat you
have to clean the house so these are
things that I grew up doing but at the
end of the day I still have to survive I
have to take care of myself right and
there's nothing wrong with that and I'm
not like I don't know your situation but
I'm saying like if if I'm trying to get
married and all the men are saying no I
don't want to marry you no I don't want
to marry you like maybe it's just
something you gotta fix like I'm not
even talking about you personally I'm
just talking about women in general if
the men don't want to marry us it's like
maybe we need to improve but women will
blame the buyer instead of fixing the
product but yeah but I think maybe women
are actually it's kind of they're going
for the wrong market like that too all
the women are throwing themselves at
like a small minority and often players
you know they're really belligerent and
how hot is that correct
um you know whereas there would be
plenty of men who would be good husbands
yeah
but that still goes with like that's the
marketing right you know what I mean
like like instead of it being everybody
else like maybe we if if yeah we're not
if we're not yeah but it's like it's
like the product is good the marketing
you know I mean the product isn't always
good it's often suspect but even when
the products you know because for a
while I was like why are the men upset
but then I started reading the numbers I
was like God damn this doesn't make us
up but it's really hard when you think
about it right in my 20s it's not that a
lot of men might say in your 20s it's
not that most men are saying I don't
want to marry you're not married
marriage material what they say is I'm
not ready yet I need to build my I need
to make sure I'm solid before I can now
provide for a household because marriage
is not no simple thing it's a business
contract you now we're going into
business together so at a younger age
unless you decide to date older if
you're going to date in your age range
at 25 most men are going to want to wait
till they are establishing they have the
money weddings are expensive marriage is
expensive and I agree with you but again
that's trying to make a guy that's
clearly not ready to be a husband a
husband
sometimes if that's all you have to pick
from no but it's not like it's not all
right
I don't know why you keep like like it's
not all you have to do you know it's not
always doubles
yeah
off camera it might be a different story
but yeah but you know this is this is
you know I'm always gonna always think
different I'm always going to defend
women I'll defend them into sometimes
but I will always defend women because
it is not everybody is just privileged
to certain situations so we have to
we're going to speak about women I don't
think about all women I wanna I wanna
say women are all privileged we have we
have female privilege in the fact that
we have
yes yes the world is Kinder to us than
men we do have female privilege yes
um can you read the super chats that
have come in I can't read them because
my laptop died
we're ready for the hate meal because
you know it's gonna be like that
delusional girl in a green yeah yeah
let's bring it I'm ready yeah can you
read it because I just I
um that's cool first time reading super
chats let's go it's hard it's harder
than you think
I think I would do it better than you do
shut up
okay um
esoteric nightmares a 37 year old baby
mama bartender blaming men
is Peak delusion
them eyes you can't have your cake and
eat it too you make bad choices you get
bad results dog MPA if she's a bartender
and can go wherever she wants when she
wants who's taking care of her daughter
is she leaving her daughter with the
grandma
them eyes this is the reality just
listen and learn something ladies
the happiest Gilmore hey pal I want you
to know even though you are not married
your show has made a much has made me a
much better wife I'm 38 and have been
married for 14 years we have never been
happier thanks for helping women
Robert Carney presidents are president
president Pied Piper the people who have
the power communist and socialists is
the female energy and Sims of the
inverted truth called lies
Andrew Andrew
JMP 34 I work in education and there are
no gender specific incentives for men to
be teachers that's absolute cap
Emmanuel Christ Christ eon
guys the guys in New York dates barely
break five figures annually maybe even
by annually just a professional Struggle
Bus laugh out loud great job on PS
Morgan Pearl
got who in the office would put up with
that
Robert Carney ladies lady on the left
could not Define love love definition
biblically biblically is The Ten
Commandments love is not a feeling is
the truth it's truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth why the Adam and
Eve judgment is what what we are
experiencing the inverted truth called
lies
huh okay
Pharaoh housewife as a married woman you
know when they don't pull out just
saying
Jacob Joseph some of the best advice I
ever got never love your job because
your job will never love you back I like
my job I don't love it
Jesus
okay
Jesus lady in the green the 50 50
concept is the result of feminism this
is what you want this is what you get
but if she was 20 I bet you men will
line up to pay for her meal because
there's a chance one can keep her
conservative
the serving Ninja
stop making the black community seem
like ignorant ain't got no money can't
do anything or figure out how to do
anything lady
Darius Horton lady stop kids go to
school they have computers okay I think
we've heard that right
I don't remember yeah all right that's
all okay thank you King very good very
good Super Chat yeah
I actually do think you did it better
than men do do everything better than
women like you know what I mean
even like being women
I was trying to think of one thing women
could do better this is how I came to
this thought I couldn't think of
anything so I was like well we're better
cooks and I looked up the Michelin chefs
I'm like damn it they're all men and
then I was like well we're better
parents and then I looked up the stats
on like single mother versus single
father I was like damn it and I couldn't
I literally couldn't find any let me
know if you guys think of anything I
just couldn't think of one thing
or like the top like it was always
dominated by men now I'm finding out we
need two teachers to do what one man
could do who runs uh the internet
probably a man right so when you do when
you do that Google search something
that's in favor of man is probably
always going to pop up first
that's what I'm saying
it's not
pretty sure it will be
not I don't live by statistics I live by
real life real situations I live the
real Life's real situations I live in
that's what I go back I don't go by
science statistics
what's what's real life what are we
seeing what are we doing every day
that's right I see men doing things yeah
men men yeah we need men we need men
yeah we need men men do things but we're
gonna do final I'm not diminishing
anybody
I'm just saying we're not as important
as we think I didn't say unimportant I
said not as important as feminism has
deluded us to belief that's my but final
thoughts go ahead and you can any social
media you you've been in men's rights
for like 10 years right uh yeah at least
yeah so guys go follow me about 10 10
years yeah yeah I've I've heard I've
heard great things so go go follow
wherever she says
what am I supposed to say right okay
yeah um Twitter is at anti-fem but
you've gone underscore between the
auntie and fembot uh Instagram is
anti-fembot without the underscore
um and yeah I have been concentrating on
um building a new life in the last
couple of years so I have been quite
quiet although I've done an article or
an essay or ever here and there made a
video here and there but I now I am
leading more
um a life that's more conducive to
pursuing my interests because my working
hours are significantly less hopefully I
will be doing some more stuff so yeah it
might be worth watching this space if
you're interested
well me hi
um you can follow me on peachy Susie
p-e-a-c-h-i-e-s-u-z-e on all platforms
on Instagram is PC shoes too because of
course they deleted my first page for
all the man-hate ice views I was asking
like who was it that took peachy Susie
yeah like yeah so you had to be two but
it was you yeah that was the first one
instagram said give us that then I made
a second one and said I'm back
back baby you can't keep me down but you
follow me there if you want to argue me
come argue me over there I have a lot of
controversial stuff up let's get it send
all that hate mail to my DM look forward
to it
if they'll just hit on you they'll like
super chat you but then they'll hit on
you I believe they call it nagging
oh yeah
go ahead
uh yeah it's Johnny Cash Out
that's my name on all the socials if
you're on Instagram it's at londondating
coach and yeah if you look and develop
this area of your life your dating life
your social life I have a workshop
coming up on the 5th of August so do
check her out on johnnycasel.com can I
ask you a question how long do you think
it would take to make me a dateable
woman
do you think I'm a dateable woman for a
man I don't know what I'm working with
yet I'm gonna need some time that's a
good answer not to try to hurt my
feelings you don't have how long do you
think it'll take
do you think I would be a difficult
client
I don't know where your patterns are yet
you know what patterns have you been
experiencing in your dating life that's
what we need to look at book them guys
he's good he's good he's good
um okay guys
how many likes are we at King
wait King what do you want to say say
what you want to say King he's he's
making some no no King say what you want
to say say it say it no like I'm not
even trying to go at you but it's more
at her so what he's good because he made
you feel good
listen he do what to say because guess
what I I was like let me see what he'll
say he he knows how to politically
answer the uh the the question right
because he could have said well maybe
you know you could be no he knows how to
say hey let's see things happen let's
see you know what I actually think he
was being honest
I'm not talking about him because I'm
looking at the way she received his
because I was I was expecting I was
expecting different and you know that
was a good answer that was a good answer
this is a genuine that was a great
answer so if you wanted to book a
service from someone you did something
done would you book the person that made
you feel good or the person that gave
you a solution directly to your problem
I'm about feelings that's my point make
me feel good
everybody wants to feel good Solutions
[Laughter]
how many likes are we at King
1052. okay 1052 guys on your way out I
know there's over there's almost 2K
people in here so hit the like button on
your way out I'd really like to get a
thousand five hundred likes um before
you know you guys all leave so like the
video subscribe to the channel sign up
to our Google form it's under the
Community post
um or like to join our community that
way you're going to be notified we're
going to do some events meetups in
London it'll be a lot of fun like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things